I'LL START THE HEARING AS
SOON AS I GET A REPUBLICAN HERE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I AM COLLEEN THE HEARING OF
THE ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC COMMITTEE.
I'D LIKE TO MEMBER AT TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ACCOUNT RUTH'S
FEELINGS ARE VACANCY TODAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MATHIS TO HEAR THIS --
OUR SUBSTITUTE VICE CHAIR.
OUR SHORTLY WILL BE --
JOINED BY ANOTHER SUBSTITUTE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY --
AND WE ARE HEARING TEN BILLS
TODAY.
A WITH TO THAT OPPOSED TO BE
CONSENT S. B. TEN FIFTY FOUR
HERTZBERG S B. ELEVEN THIRTY
THREE PORTANTINO.
WE'LL BE STARTING WITH A SPECIAL
ORDER BUSINESS S. B. TWO TWELVE
JACKSON.
ARE.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT
WE WILL HOPEFULLY HAVE ONE
SHORTLY.
ARTS CENTER JACKSON --
I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED VERY HARD
ON THIS BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR BEING HERE
--
EARLY BECAUSE I KNOW YOU HAVE
ANOTHER COMMITTEE CHAIR.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
PLEASE PROCEED AND MISTER FAMILY
MEMBER TING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS WELL.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OUR
AND MEMBERS I APPRECIATE --
THE THE ABILITY TO PRESENT THIS
SITE IN A SPECIAL ORDER --
THIS IS A OF MEASURE THAT I HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS IT'S A BILL THAT CREATES A
COMPREHENSIVE STATEWIDE.
PRODUCER PAID TAKE BACK PROGRAM
FOR HOME GENERATED
PHARMACEUTICAL DRUGS AND MEDICAL
SHARPS.
THIS BILL WOULD SAID A STATEWIDE
PROGRAM.
UNDER WHICH CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
WOULD BE ABLE TO SAFELY AND
CONVENIENTLY DISPOSE OF MEDICAL
WASTE AN UNUSED MEDICAL
PRODUCTS.
GIVING SOLUTION TO A PROBLEM
THAT VIRTUALLY ALL CALIFORNIANS
KNOW TOO WELL.
EACH AND EVERYONE OF US WHEN WE
HAD CERTAIN HEALTH ISSUES OR
LOVED ONES HAVE HAD THEM.
WERE ALL PRESCRIBED ENORMOUS
AMOUNTS OF MEDICATION OR AT
LEAST SOME MEDICATION WE DON'T
NECESSARILY TAKE IT ALL.
AND AT SOME POINT THAT THE
ACCUMULATES IN OUR MEDICINE
CABINETS AND WE LOOK AT AND
WONDER WHAT IS THAT FOR WHAT AM
I SUPPOSED TO DO WITH THIS.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT PEOPLE
FLUSHING THESE PRODUCTS DOWN THE
TOILET WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT
THEM PUTTING THEM.
ARE IN OUR OUR WATER SUPPLY AND
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT THEM OUT
THERE IN THE WORLD SO THE
CHILDREN OR ADULTS ARE CONFUSED
BY THE MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
THERE.
AND TAKE THEM WE'VE SEEN A HUGE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
A ADMITTED TO OUR HOSPITALS
PARTICULARLY SENIORS FOR
CONFUSING MEDICATIONS.
WE KNOW YOUNG PEOPLE FOR REASONS
THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY BEYOND ME
WILL TAKE OF THEIR OF
MEDICATIONS PRESCRIPTIONS AT
THAT THEIR PARENTS HAVE IN
THERE.
OF MEDICINE CABINETS AND TAKE
THEM TO PARTIES WHICH THEY THEN
WILL THROW INTO A FISH BOWL AND
POPPED SOME DECIDED TO SEE
WHATEVER IT IS THE BIG KICK FROM
WHATEVER MOM WAS TAKING FOR
WHATEVER.
A A IT THERE'S JUST TOO MANY OF
THOSE AND OF COURSE ALL LET.
AND DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING WHO'S BEEN
WORKING ON THE SHARPS ELEMENT OF
THIS TO PERHAPS SHARE A FEW
THOUGHTS I PERSONALLY HAVE HAD
THAT EXPERIENCE IS A CANCER
SURVIVOR I WAS TAKING ALL SORTS
OF MEDICATIONS OR AT LEAST THEY
WERE PRESCRIBED TO ME FOR
WHATEVER THIS.
WAS THAT I WAS DOING OF THAT WAS
THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO DO.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THANKFULLY
IT WAS AWHILE AGO A LONG TIME
AGO.
I LOOKED AT MY MEDICINE CABINET
I HAD NO.
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO HAVE
TAKEN THEM FOR AND THE QUESTION
WAS NOW WITH TWO I DO WITH THEM?
AND THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT I
THINK MOST OF US HAVE EITHER FOR
OURSELVES OR FOOD CARED FOR OUR
PARENTS OR ELDAR ELDERLY.
THERE'S JUST WHICH WE HAVE NOT
RECOGNIZED THE NEED TO OR THE A
THAT WHAT IS REQUIRED TO REMOVE
REMOVE FEES OF MEDICATIONS AND
DANGEROUS PRODUCTS --
FROM OUR HOME SO --
YEAH I HAVE WORKED ON THIS --
AS I MENTIONED FOR MANY YEARS AS
A RESULT OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE
AND JUST RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS.
WHEN THESE ARE ITEMS ARE NOT
DISPOSED OF SAFELY?
THE WASTE IS SUBJECT TO ABUSE WE
HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT FROM OUR
WATER COME DISTRICTS BECAUSE
PEOPLE WILL DUMP THESE DOWN THE
TOILET THEY INFEST OUR WATER
SYSTEMS THEY ALSO CLOG THE
DRAINS.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T ALL
NECESSARILY --
DISINTEGRATE SO THE HARM TO
SOCIETY IS NOT JUST THE PERSONAL
OR CHOSE TO PUBLIC HEALTH.
THESE IMPROPERLY DISCARDED
MEDICAL WASTE SORT OF SERIOUS
CONCERN TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO
THE ENVIRONMENT.
AND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL YOU
FIND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT HAVE TO DEAL WITH
DISCARDED MEDICAL WASTE AT GREAT
COST TO THEIR RESOURCES.
THEY PAY FOR THESE ARE A
SHERATON AND PUBLIC SAFETY
PEOPLE WHO PROVIDE THESE BINS
AND DO THESE TAKE BACK PROGRAMS.
THE TAXPAYER MONEY THAT IS USED
FOR THIS PURPOSE AND THESE
IMPROPERLY DISPOSED OF WAYS ARE
SCORCHED THE PUBLIC PLACES AGAIN
WITH THE SHARP STUTTER --
ON THE STREETS AND I CAN TELL
YOU IN OUR BEACHES WHERE OUR
KIDS WANTED GO TO RECREATION
THERE'S A HYPODERMIC NEEDLE
THERE THAT'S EXPOSED HER CHEST
BENEATH THE SAND THAT IS A
DANGER TO THEM --
WE WE HAVE.
TO WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM.
SO -- AGAIN
OR LANDFILLS THE AQUATIC SYSTEMS
LIKE THAT GOES ON BUT THE
SITUATION IS NOT ALL THAT
GRAHAM.
BECAUSE WE ARE ABLE TO AND WE
CAN ADDRESS THIS IN A BETTER
WAY.
AND THANKS TO LOCAL EFFORTS
ACROSS SEVERAL CALIFORNIA
COUNTIES AND STATEWIDE IN
PROVINCIAL.
OF PROGRAMS IN WASHINGTON STATE
AND SOON TO BE IN NEW YORK STATE
WE TRIED AND GOT TESTED MODELS
THAT CAN BE SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IN COOPERATION AND WITH THE
PARTNER KEL PHARMACEUTICAL AND
MEDICAL DEVICE INDUSTRIES WE ARE
ACTUALLY EVERYONE'S AT THE TABLE
AND WE ARE.
A DISCUSSING THE ISSUE WE HAVE A
BILL BEFORE YOU THAT WE
RECOGNIZE I'D NEED SOME OF
CONTINUED WORKING WERE ALL
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AND
HAVING IN TALKING WITH THE
CHAIR.
RECOGNIZING HIS INTEREST IN
HELPING WHICH IS GREATLY
APPRECIATED.
ARDEN AND WE TALK ABOUT LOCAL
EFFORTS I SHOULD NOTE THAT JUST
THIS VERY MORNING.
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A RESOLUTION
SUPPORTING THIS BILL IN CONCEPT
HIGHLIGHTING THE CONTINUED
EFFORT.
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO GET
THIS DONE AND THE INTEREST ON
THE PART OF THE COUNTY TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM
COMPREHENSIVELY.
IF WE'RE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT
HERE FIRST AND THAT'S THE GOAL
RATHER THAN HAVE A WHOLE BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES WITH
DIFFERENT STANDARDS AND
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS.
A THIS IS A STATEWIDE EFFORT
THIS MEASURE IS AN ATTEMPT TO
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT IS
COMPREHENSIVE YET COMP A
COMPREHENSIBLE TO ALL OF THE
PARTIES INVOLVED.
ANDA AGAIN MANY YEARS OF
CONVERSATION A WE ARE HERE AND
IT ADDITION --
I HAVE MY ONE OF MY CO AUTHORS
WITH ME TODAY --
WE ALSO HAVE JASON SMELSER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE WITH THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS THAT MAY EXIST.
I WANNA THANK YOU I'M REALLY
THIS WE'VE TURNED A CORNER I AM
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
EVERYBODY IS NOW RECOGNIZING THE
PROBLEM IN COMING TOGETHER TO
TRY TO SOLVE IT --
BEFORE WE STARTED LIKE TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM [inaudible]
AS QUIRK.
HERE QUIRK HERE LACKEY
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
MATHIS MATHIS HERE [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA HERE HOLDEN.
WANTED TO CHEER MERETZ VIEW HERE
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU.
UP.
THANK YOU RICHARD LET ME ALSO
JUST --
THANK -- MY
PARTNERS IN THIS EFFORT CENTER
JACKSON AS WELL TO SOME THE
MEMBER GRAY THIS HAS REALLY BEEN
NOW.
PROJECT THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS AND WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE --
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS WE WE ARE
VERY FORTUNATE TO LIVE IN A
COUNTRY WHERE WE HAVE EXTREMELY
ADVANCED HEALTH CARE.
AN EX EXTREMELY ADVANCE WORK.
BUT WITH ON SOME OF THAT
HEALTHCARE IN TERMS OF MEDICINE
AS WELL AS SHARPS WE DON'T HAVE
THE BEST SYSTEM OF HOW WE TAKE
THAT PRODUCT BACK.
A IN THE BAR WE STREAM AT THE
BUT OUR STREETS I ENTERED IN THE
ALL MANY OF THE WRONG PLACES SO
THAT I'M VERY PROUD TO DATE TO
BE PRESENTING [inaudible]
STATEWIDE EXTENDER PRODUCER
RESPONSIBILITY HERE STANDING
WITH A CENTER JACKSON'S A MEMBER
GRAY IT AND REALLY PUTTING THIS
FORWARD POT WE'VE HAD SOME LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS REALLY STARTING IN
MOVING THE BALL FORWARD.
BUT WHAT I WOULD SAY AS WELL MY
MY CITY HAS DONE SO WELL WE
REALLY ARE BEST SERVED WITH THE
CONSISTENT STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
OF THAT BILLY A PROVIDES
RESPONSIBILITY ACROSS THE BOARD
SO WE CAN REALLY SHARE
RESPONSIBILITY BETWEEN
GOVERNMENT AND INDUSTRY IN
REALLY GETTING THE PRODUCTS
AFTER THEY'VE BEEN USED.
OUT OF PEOPLE'S HOMES INTO INTO
THEIR PROPER DISPOSAL STREAMS.
ARE AGAIN --
THIS BILL.
FINAL PRODUCT BUT IT'S A HUGE
STEP FORWARD I THINK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE --
IT NEEDS TO HELP US --
MOVE THIS FORWARD AS WASHINGTON
HAS DONE AS WELL AS WHAT NEW
YORK IS POISED TO DO.
AT THE QUICKLY VERY PROUD OF S.
B. TO TWELVE TODAY --
BUT KNOWING THAT WE STILL HAVE
MORE WORK TO DO IN THE FUTURE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS FOR NOT TO
DRESS.
S. B..
TWO TWELVE YOU KNOW MEMBERS
COCKETT PIECE LEGISLATION.
OFTEN REQUIRE MORE WORK THAN OUR
TYPICAL PROCESS AFFORD FOUR OR
DEADLINES.
AND I KNOW IN OUR DEDICATION.
THAT WE ALL SHARE AND TRY TO
IMPROVE THE PLIGHT OF
CALIFORNIANS --
WE OFTEN RUSH LEGISLATION ALONG.
AND WE FEEL TO GIVE OURSELVES
WITH AN EXTRA TIME [inaudible]
TO FLUSH OUT ALL THE ISSUE WORK
WITH ALL THE PARTIES AND COME UP
WITH THE COLLABORATIVE PLUGS ON
ON BIG ISSUES THAT THAT REALLY
ARE.
EVERYBODY CAN BEND IT FROM.
FROM IN IN IN IN CONTRAST TO
THAT.
S. B. TO TWELVE HAS BEEN THE
RIGHT PROCESS.
IT'S BEEN BOTH HOUSES.
WE HAVE WORKED COLLABORATORY
OVER MULTI YEARS AND YOU KNOW I
WAS RIGHT TO THE CALL THEM TO
YOUR SESSIONS FOR A REASON.
WE CAN TAKE OUR TIME WE CAN DO
IT RIGHT.
I WANNA.
THANK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAFF FOR YOUR TAKING A AN
EFFORT AT ADDRESSING SUMMER
DIFFICULT.
ISSUES AND WORKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND ON AND I THINK
THERE'S THERE'S DEFINITE
WILLINGNESS HERE BY BOTH
BUSINESS AND CONSUMER GROUPS. TO
GET A TAKE BACK PROGRAM THAT
WORKS.
THAT RUNS BOTH FROM.
A A PERSPECTIVE THE PUBLIC IN
THE MANUFACTURERS WHO ULTIMATELY
WILL FUNDED RUN THE PROGRAM.
THIS BILL IS GOING THE RIGHT
DIRECTION A AYE STERLING
CONFIDENT THAT WHEN HE ARRIVES
ON THE FLOOR EYES MISTING SAID A
IT CONTINUES TO BE A WORK IN
PROGRESS WERE STILL WORKING
THROUGH THOSE ISSUES.
BUT WERE --
CLOSELY ARRIVING AT A AT A VERY
VERY PROMISING FINISH I THINK A
BILL THAT ALL PARTIES A AND ALL
MEMBERS.
CAN BE PROUD VOTE FOR WHEN IT
HITS THE A FLOOR SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WORK AND
I APPRECIATE THE HEARING ON THIS
AFTERNOON.
BOB BEFORE WE GO FROM HERE SO AS
THE AUTHORS HAVE STATED A WE WE
DON'T THINK THE BELLAS IN FINAL
FORM.
A WE OURSELVES JUST AT THE BELL
REALLY JUST HIT [inaudible]
THE WHEN INTO PRINT JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO SO WE'RE NOT PREPARED
TO OFFER AMENDMENTS.
ARM WHAT WE'D LIKE TO DO TODAY
IS HERE FROM THE SUPPORTERS.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE FIFTY AND
AT IN YOU CAN DETERMINE THE
LENGTH YOU'D LIKE TO GO TO BUT
FOR THE WE'LL CALL THEM
OPPONENTS BUT LET'S JUST SAY
PEOPLE WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHANGES
IN THE BILL.
I'D LIKE TO ALLOCATE ABOUT
FIFTEEN MINUTES AND WHEN THE
TIME COMES FOR THAT.
IF THE VARIOUS GROUPS HE'D LIKE
A ONE TWO OR THREE MINUTES COULD
ARE COME UP AND WILL TRY AND
ORGANIZE --
THE YEAH AT THAT SAID THAT AS
MANY PEOPLE OUT WITH MANY
CONCERNS IT'S POSSIBLE GET
ADDRESS.
BUT AND THEN I WANT TO HEAR FROM
THE MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE.
OUGHT TO GET THEIR INPUT AS TO
WHAT THEY THINK MOST NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL.
SO MR ADJACENT SMELSER PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS --
MY NAME'S JASON SHELTERED WITH
SUGAR AND CREAM HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL A VERY PROUD
TO BE HERE TODAY WITH --
THE SENATOR IN THESE TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
THEY SAID IT BEST SO WELL BE
VERY BRIEF --
CPSC TUXEDOS AN ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS --
TO HAVE MANUFACTURERS MITIGATE
THE END OF LIFE CONSEQUENCES OF
PRODUCTS THEY MAKE UP NOT EVERY
PRODUCT A NOT EVERY PRODUCT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE FOR THE
POLICY THAT WE PITCH.
AND THEY FALL INTO FOUR
CATEGORIES REALLY OUT VOTE THEY
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT AND OF LIFE
IMPACT IN ONE OF THE FOLLOWING
FOUR CATEGORIES ONE PUBLIC
HEALTH LIKE DRUGS.
BUT YOU OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH LIKE SHARKS.
A THREE ENVIRONMENTAL AT THE
QUIRK YOUR THERMOSTATS
[inaudible]
DRUGS.
I AND FOR ACOSTA LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IS THE COST TO DEAL
WITH CERTAIN PRODUCTS THAT ARE
THAT ARE DIFFICULT TO MANAGE AT
THE END OF LIFE SICK MATTRESSES.
I'M ALL PROGRAMS OF THAT OUR
HOPEFULLY WILL EXISTING OR
ALREADY DO EXIST.
I AM I TO ALSO JUST WHEN I THINK
OF THE THREE MEMBERS AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF --
FOR THEIR HARD WORK THIS IS IN A
VERY LONG PROCESS A LOT OF
MEETINGS A LOT OF CONVERSATIONS
LOT OF DEDICATION.
A ON EVERYBODY'S PART I AND AND
ESPECIALLY WITH THE THREE
MEMBERS A ALL VERY INDIVIDUAL
IMPORTANT THIS PROCESS SO I
THINK EACH ONE OF YOU
PERSONALLY.
AFTER YOUR EFFORTS HERE.
I'M VERY QUICKLY --
THE DEBATE THE OTHER HAS BEEN A
DEBATE FOR YEARS --
IT'S OVER TEN YEARS I REMEMBER
ONE OF THE FIRST.
BILL INTRODUCTION REPORTS ARE
VIEWED AS A LOBBYIST IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE I REMEMBER ASKING
MYSELF WHAT IS A SHARP AND WHY
AM I READING ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T KNOW.
AB WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON AT LEAST
THAT LONG IF NOT LONGER --
SO WHY IS A PROGRAM NEED IT UP
ON THE DRUG SIDE VERY SIMPLE --
ENVIRONMENTAL CONTAMINATION IS
ONE ISSUE.
OTHERS THE PRESENCE OF UP A
PHARMACEUTICAL INGREDIENTS IN
THE NATION'S WATERWAYS --
COMES FROM A COMBINATION OF
EXCRETION --
UNDER THE BUSH WHITE HOUSE
OFFICE OF NATIONAL DRUG CONTROL
POLICY AND THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY IN THE U. S. EP
EPA ALL RELEASED.
A DRUG DISPOSAL GUIDELINES ARE
BECAUSE AND I QUOTE I IMPROPER
DRUG DISPOSAL OF THE
PRESCRIPTION FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
AND SOCIETAL CONCERN.
A SO FOR DRUGS AT THE SECOND
ISSUE OF PUBLIC HEALTH A CLEARLY
WE HAVE A A PRESCRIPTION DRUG
OPIOID ACT EPIDEMIC IN THIS
COUNTRY --
IT'S PLAGUING --
FAMILIES ALL OVER THE PLACE --
A PRESIDENT OBAMA'S NATIONAL
DRUG CONTROL STRATEGY IDENTIFIED
FOUR MAJOR AREAS OF FOCUS TO
DEAL WITH THIS AND ONE OF THEM I
WAS TO DEVELOP CONVENIENT
ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
PRESCRIPTION DRUG DISPOSAL
PROGRAMS TO HELP DECREASE THE
SUPPLY OF UNUSED DRUGS IN THE
HOME.
US SO AGAIN ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERN AND A PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN THAT'S BEING ADDRESSED
BY THIS BILL SPECIFICALLY BY
TAKE BACK PROGRAM.
I SO SECOND PRODUCT OBVIOUSLY
IT'S SHARPS AND THIS ONE I THINK
IT'S FAR EASIER TO UNDERSTAND A
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE VERY
ASPIRATIONAL ABOUT OUR RECYCLING
IN THAT'S A VERY GOOD THING.
I WITH THAT REQUIRES A IS FOR A
EMPLOYEES ON THE LOCAL LEVEL AYE
IN PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
AND IMAGINE A CONVEYOR BELT A
LITTLE WHITER THAN THIS TABLE
WITH A SOLID WASTE MOVING DOWN.
ALL THESE FOLKS HAVE TO STAND
THERE AND REACH INTO THIS PILE
OUT TO PULL OUT INDIVIDUAL ITEMS
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR
UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE ARE
SHARKS THAT ARE IN THERE.
A IN THE DO YOU GET STUCK IN THE
GET STUCK TOO FREQUENTLY I'M SO
VERY SIMPLY THE SHARKS ASPECT OF
THIS IS AN OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH CONCERNS.
AYE IT'S GONE ON FOR FAR TOO
LONG [inaudible]
I'M.
SENATOR JACKSON RT WALKED
THROUGH THE BILL AND I KNOW
WE'VE GOT A LOT OF QUESTIONS A
POTENTIALLY OFFENSIVE COMMENTS
FROM THE NOT QUITE OPPOSITION IS
THE CHAIR POINTED OUT.
US WITHOUT ALL JUST OUT
RESPECTFULLY URGENT AYE VOTE AND
SAY THAT WE VERY MUCH LOOK YOU
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU.
I AND ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
FINISH UP THIS PROCESS.
THANK YOU ARE FOR BEING BRIEFED
MR SCHMELZER [inaudible]
ALRIGHT SHOW.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS IS OUR
SERVE CLEAR OUT AS MUCH OF THE
TABLE AS WE CAN AND HAVE PEOPLE
COME UP?
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK FOR ONE TWO
OR THREE MINUTES BOB LET'S HAVE
THE PEOPLE FIRST ON THE DRUG
PART.
AND THEN SECONDLY ON THE SHARPS.
SO ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON
DRUGS COME UP NOW.
AND IF YOU COULD GIVE COULD YOU
GO AND TO BE YEAH WE'D LIKE. TO
TO GET AS MANY CHAIRS AS
POSSIBLE UP HERE [inaudible]
FIGURE OUT.
JEFF THE DRUGS FOLKS COULD SIT
AT THE TABLE. OH I'M SORRY
SHOULD OF HAD SUPPORTERS SPURS
--
IF THERE'S TO MEET CHIU
SUPPORTERS --
COULD YOU SPEAK UP NOW.
I'M SURE THERE ARE SOME.
THANK YOU OF MY STAFFER
CORRECTING ME ME TO SUPPORTERS
GO TO THE MICROPHONE.
THOSE WHO ARE.
GOTTA MAKE COMMENTS ON THE BILL
COME TO THE CHAIR.
GOOD OF YOU CAN THAT'S YOU GONNA
COMMENT ON THE BILL SIT DOWN.
YOU'RE GONNA MEET TO OUR GO TO
THE MICROPHONE.
OKAY MAY CHOOSE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CARE ROSS ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF STOCKTON IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
RAINY TO CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
RETIRED AMERICANS CALIFORNIA'S
DISABILITY RIGHTS AND STRONG AND
OLDER WOMEN'S LEAGUE.
STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MELISSA EMMA WAS
SHY ORDER ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL SEARCH OF ACTION
COUNCIL THE SOLID WASTE
ASSOCIATION OF NORTH AMERICA.
THE WESTERN POSTURE WASTE
MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY AT THE CITY
OF SANTA MONICA THE BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS FOR THE COUNTIES OF
THE BUTTE MINUTE MENDOCINO
HUMBLE AND SHASTA OWN SUPPORT.
AS WELL AS THE SAN FRANCISCO
DEPARTMENT OF THE ENVIRONMENT
SUPPORTIVE IN CONCEPT OF THE
GOALS OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JUST
CA.GOV AT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES IN SUPPORT.
MARY PINTO IN SUPPORT FOR THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
KAREN EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON GREEN ON
THE HALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT SINCE
PART THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND SUPPORT.
THERESA BURKE RICH ON BEHALF OF
THE LOCAL --
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HILL THE BAY SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION SOME GENERATION
ADVISORS AND ALAMEDA COUNTY
WASTE MANAGEMENT AUTHORITY AND
SUPPORT.
AFTERNOON JACK ANDERSON WITH THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT THE ONLY THING
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE CHANGE
IN THIS BILL IS.
AS MUCH AND FORSMAN AS WE CAN
HAVE THANK YOU [inaudible]
EXCELLENT.
ALRIGHT SHOW THE PEOPLE AT THE
TABLE IF YOU COULD TAKE PERHAPS
A TWO AND A HALF MINUTES.
EACH OR I THEREABOUTS AND LET
THIS KNOW WHAT CONCERNS.
WELL NOW WE'VE GOT ONE MORE SO
THIS IS ON THE DRUGS TWO MINUTES
EACH.
AND THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
SHARP [inaudible]
SO -- MADAM.
MY NAME IS SANDRA CHAVEZ A
MOTHER WHO LOST A CHILD BECAUSE
OF A BLOOD BORNE PATHOGEN.
I'VE COME HERE TO SPEAK BECAUSE
I LOST MY SON WHO WITNESSED IT
AND I'M.
AND WE'VE ALREADY HEARD FROM
SUPPORTERS IS THERE SOMETHING
YOU WANT CHANGED IN THE BELL
WE'RE HEARING NOW FROM THE
PEOPLE WANT THINGS CHANGED IN
THE BILL.
ARE IF YOU JUST ARE GIVING
SUPPORT.
I CAN GIVE YOU THAT. FIFTEEN
SECONDS YOURSELF BUT I
UNDERSTAND YOU'VE LOST A SON.
AND GO AHEAD.
MY SON --
BUT HIS DISEASE PROGRESSED IV
DRUG USE.
AND I I AM HERE IN SUPPORT
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT IF.
WE WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HAVE
A SHARP CONTAINER IN HER HOME.
THAT -- IT
THAT WOULD HAVE HELPED BECAUSE
THAT WE ENDED UP HAVING TO KICK
ME OUT OF OUR HOUSE BECAUSE IT.
OF MY FEAR OF EXPOSURE TO BLOOD
POURED PATHOGENS --
I'M SORRY I BUILDING LIFE FIRST
TIME I JUST WOULD WANNA SAY THAT
I SUPPORTED AND I BELIEVE THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE.
YOU KNOW I'M ESSAY FOR ACCESS TO
IV -- YOU
KNOW TO PREVENT IV DRUG USE A
THINK OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M TIM CONTRA FROM SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY.
SENATORS COUNTY HAS HAD THE A
DRUG IN CHARGE TAKE BACK PROGRAM
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND SIX EVERY PHARMACY
IN OUR COUNTY PARTICIPATES.
THEY TAKE BACK DRUGS AND SHARPS
FROM CONSUMERS [inaudible] FOR
FREE.
SO WE WANTED TO SHARE WITH YOU
THAT AFTER TWELVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE.
WE KNOW THESE PROGRAMS WORK
THEY'RE VERY POPULAR WITH THE
PUBLIC THE VERY POPULAR WITH THE
PHARMACIES.
THEY'RE VERY INEXPENSIVE.
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WE
OCCASIONALLY HEAR ABOUT THINGS
THAT MICHAEL WRONG WE CAN ASSURE
YOU THAT AFTER TWELVE YEARS THEY
HAVE NOT WE HAVE HAD NO
PROBLEMS.
AS FAR AS POTENTIAL CHANGES IN
THE BILL.
AS I MENTIONED EVERY PHARMACY IN
OUR COUNTY PARTICIPATES.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
CONVENIENCE STANDARD IN THE
EXISTING BILL IS THE STARTING
POINT.
THESE PROGRAMS WORK BETTER THE
MORE PHARMACIES YOU HAVE AND
IDEALLY IF EVERYBODY IS AN
SECONDLY --
BECAUSE THEY ARE EXISTING VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS WE URGE YOU
NOT TO INCLUDE ANY PREEMPTION IN
THE BILL WE THINK THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU --
MISTER PHILLY PAY FOR WENT AS
SAKE YOU CHAIRMAN QUIRK.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE A
SLEEPY POINT IS HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH
AND MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA --
IT WOULD.
A LOT OF THIS WORK HAS BEEN
INFORMED OF BY THE RECENT STATE
AUDIT THAT INDICATED THAT A
ALMOST 90% OF CALIFORNIANS.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO AVAIL
THEMSELVES OF COLLECTION SITES
UP BUT ANOTHER THING THAT THE
AUDIT INFORMED US IS THAT THERE
ISN'T A CENTRALIZED UNIFIED.
A PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE COLLECTION SITES.
ACTUALLY WORKED THE ABSOLUTE
BENEFIT OF CONSUMERS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS FARM UP AS
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN THE
CONVERSATION --
WITH YOUR STAFF A OBVIOUSLY
SENATOR JACKSON ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
TANG AND GRAY AND FOR THAT WE'RE
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO VOICE
OUR CONCERNS. TO THE POINT THAT
WAS MADE EARLIER ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL IS NOT --
FINALIZES AS RECENT AS THIS
MORNING AS A MATTER OF EXAMPLE
WE'VE HAD SOME ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOUR COMMITTEE AND AND THE
STAFF.
A AS HOW IT RELATES TO
CONFIDENTIALITY BUT AS I'M
REMINDED OF BY MY EXPERIENCE
HERE IN THE BUILDING THAT'S WHAT
THE SUMMERS --
FOR INTO WILL KEEP WORKING
EARNESTLY WITH.
THAT --
MOVES A BILL HERE THAT THAT
MEETS YOUR EXPECTATIONS BUT FOR
THE MOMENT OF FORMA FINDS ITSELF
NEUTRAL BUT A VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE EFFORTS BY.
A EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE STAKEHOLDER PROCESS
[inaudible]
CURRENT [inaudible]
AMISH NEITHER.
JENNIFER SITE ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
CHAIN DRUG STORES AYE WE ARE
BOTH IN THE CATEGORY OF DRUGS
AND SHARPS AND SO I THOUGHT I'D
COME UP NOW IN AND AT LEAST
EXPRESSED SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
YET WE ARE AND SUPPORTS IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SO OUR
PHARMACIES VERY MUCH WANT TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION --
AND WE ARE VERY VERY INTERESTED
IN BEING PART OF THE SOLUTION
HERE AND THIS BILL AND WE ARE.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE AUTHOR
SPONSORS AND I'M THE COMMITTEE
--
IN MOVING THIS FORWARD AND WANT
TO BE ACTED PRETTY DEFENSE --
IN IN A PROGRAM HERE IN THE
STATE LET ME FIRST PREFACE THAT
I'M UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS POINT
IN TIME WHERE OPPOSE MUST
AMENDED ON THE BILL AND WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT WE FEEL THE BILL NEED TO BE
CLARIFIED WITH A LITTLE BIT MORE
CLEAR DIRECTION.
ON HOW THE BILL BE IMPLEMENTED
AND ENFORCED.
JUST A FEW QUICK EXAMPLES OF
WHAT THOSE COULD BE --
THERE ARE CERTAIN --
THRESHOLDS AND HOW AND THERE
WOULD BE COLLECTION SITES AND
TAKE BACK PROGRAMS AND
REQUIREMENTS --
FOR HOW PHARMACIES PARTICIPATE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
CLEAR AND IT'S CLEARLY ENFORCED
AND M. ISN'T HAVE AT COUNTY
THRESHOLD AND IF YOU'RE IN
ALPINE COUNTY THAT'S VERY MUCH
DIFFERENT THAN IT IS LA COUNTY.
AND SO THERE'S A LOT OF CONCERNS
AND QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY -- BY THE
RETAIL PHARMACIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEY WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE THOSE
ADDRESSED --
IN THE BILL AND LASTLY AND WITH
RESPECT TO SHARPS --
SHARPE SERVED VERY DIFFERENT
DISPOSAL.
SYSTEM THAN A DRAW THAN DRUGS --
PHARMACIES HAVE NOT BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF DISPOSAL OF SHARPS
AND THERE ARE MANY PHARMACIES
THAT ACTUALLY ACTIVELY
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE IN --
DRUG TAKE BACK --
BUT THEY ARE NOT AS THAT THEY
HAVE NOT HISTORICALLY BEEN AS
INVOLVED IN SHARPE'S TAKE BACK
AT LEAST FOR COLLECTION SITES
AND SO WE WOULD REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S SOME
SPECIFIC DISCUSSION ABOUT SHARKS
THAT BURGER.
THANK YOU MICHELLE REVERSE WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA FARM.
ASSOCIATION ANA ECHO THE
COMMENTS [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES SNYDER AND CPJ WORK
WHERE YOU APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
A COMMENT AND AGAIN WE HAVE THE
SAME CONCERNS AND IT'S RELIGIOUS
CLARIFICATION WE ABSOLUTELY
SUPPORT THE OVERALL GOALS OF
THIS LEGISLATION AND WE'RE
CONFIDENT THAT THE END RESULT IS
GOING TO BE SOMETHING THAT.
WE CAN ALL LIVE WITH BUT AGAIN
JUST SOME ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES FOR*.
ON THE BILL THAT STATES THAT
PHARMACIES SHALL MAKE A
REASONABLE EFFORT TO BECOME A
COLLECTOR AND THERE'S NO
DEFINITION OF WHAT REASONABLE
IS.
AND THERE IS AS YOU KNOW AN
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM IN THIS HI
YOU IN FOR SOMETHING THAT ISN'T
CLEARLY DEFINED SO AGAIN WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
CLEAR DEFINITION OF WHAT THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE WERE ALSO
HOPEFUL THAT IN ORDER TO BE A
PARTICIPANT IN THIS PROGRAM SOME
OTHER IDEAS HER --
WAYS TO CLICK THE MEDICATIONS
WILL BE CONSIDERED OTHER THAN
JUST RECEPTACLES THERE ARE OTHER
MECHANISMS OUT THERE THERE ARE
DEVICES CURRENTLY ON THE MARKET
TO AND DE ACTIVATE THE DRUGS
IT'S A SIMPLE LITTLE ENVELOPE
YOU POUR THE DRUGS AND YOU MIX
IT AROUND IN THIRTY SECONDS
LATER.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT CAN BE
EASILY THROWN AWAY SO WE'D LIKE
TO SEE SOME OF THOSE TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WAYS FOR
PHARMACIES TO BE ABLE TO COMPLY
IN AGAIN.
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR THE WORK
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER OVER THE SUMMER.
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY HELPFUL
CHO HAD. TO KAREN MEMBERS MARIN
HIGGINS ON BEHALF OF VIACOM AND
IT'S OVER ONE THOUSAND LIFE
SCIENCE COMPANIES MEMBERS ARE
MEMBERS ARE --
BIOMEDICAL COMPANIES --
AND SHARP COMPANIES BOTH SO WE
ARE ALSO AN OPPOSING LET'S
AMENDED POSITION AND WE WOULD
LOVE TO BE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION GOING FORWARD WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD AND THAT DISCUSSION MOVE
FORWARD TODAY --
BUT WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE ADDRESSED
IN THE PROCESS TOO AMONG THOSE
ARE.
PLACING GUARDRAILS AROUND THE
FUNDING SINCE IT'S MANUFACTURED
FUNDING BILL AND WE DON'T WANT
IT TO BE SO OPEN ENDED WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE SOME DISCUSSION ON
THAT.
HOW YOU DEAL WITH PRODUCT IN A
CLINICAL SETTING AND THE
INTERPLAY BETWEEN THE STATEWIDE
ORDINANCE AND THE LOCAL
ORDINANCES SO WITH THAT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSIONS AND
WE THANK COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK?
THANK YOU THAT'S VERY HELPFUL.
MISTER HARRIMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FRED MAIN ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION. FOR ACCESSIBLE
MEDICINE WHICH ARE THAT.
GENERIC OF PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURERS IN THE OUR COUNTRY
AT THE TIME.
ASSOCIATION HAS UNOPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED PROVISION OUR POSITION
THAT WE PRIVATE PROVIDED NOT.
EXTENSIVE WITH THAT'S OKAY WE
JUST WANNA HEAR THE AMENDMENT
PART PASS OUT. TWO PROVISIONS
THAT WE'D LIKE THAT COMMITTEE TO
LOOK AT ARE THE COVERAGE OF
WHO'S IN --
PROGRAM RIGHT NOW IT SAID
MANUFACTURERS A AS DEFINED WILL
WIND UP PAYING THE P. S.
ULTIMATELY TO BE ESTABLISHED WE
THINK.
OF THE STREAM OF COMMERCE SHOULD
BE A MORE EXPANSIVE IN THAT IN
SECOND ON THE ALLOCATION.
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO --
GUIDE GUIDE RAILS AS WAS POINTED
OUT ON HOW THE FEE WOULD BE A
ALLOCATED A WE THINK THE BILL
SHOULD BE MORE.
A SPECIFIC ON THAT WE THINK --
THIS --
ALLOCATION A SHOULD BE BASED ON
A REVENUE A RATHER THAN --
VOLUME AND HOPE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THAT OVER THE
SUMMER GREAT THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD ITS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
DON'T LEAVE YOU HANGING THE CASE
YOU ASKED FOR SHARPS PEOPLE BUT
YEAH SHARPS SHARP IS GOOD OKAY
WE CAN START ON SHARPE'S NECK
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THEM ANYWAY.
IT WE RESPECT WOMEN OPPOSE LET.
ADDRESS THE SHARPS PROGRAM --
TO COMBAT THE LOGISTICAL AND
REGULATORY DIFFER EXIST.
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH OF THE AUTHORS AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDER GROUPS
OVER THE SUMMER TO GET THAT DONE
BY AUGUST.
I WILL AFFECT SENATOR AND TIE
HER CO AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FOR SO WHAT DO YOUR METICULOUS
CONCERNS NOW AT WORK AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'D ALL LIKE
TO HEAR.
OKAY THINK AT THAT THE BIG PIECE
TO BE SMALLER AND DIFFERENT SO
CONVENIENT STANDARDS ARE PRETTY
IMPORTANT --
DE A REGULATION AND IS TO THE
EXTENT OF THE PROGRAM'S CO
MINGLED WITH WITH DRUGS AND
SHARPE'S THAT'S A PROBLEM FOR US
SOON -- AND
I THINK GETTING SOME SORT OF
CREDIT FOR SOME EXISTING TAKE
BACK EFFORTS THAT SOME OF THE
MANUFACTURERS ARE DOING TODAY
WOULD BE VERY VERY HELPFUL.
GOOD GETTING US OFF.
ON THAT SIDE BECAUSE IT BUT WHEN
I THINK THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF
FOR ALL ALL YOUR TIME ATTENTION
TO OUR ISSUES AND I LOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH HAVE BEEN OVER THE
SUMMER [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALL BROADWAY
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES SHE
ASIAN --
VERY SIMILAR SITUATION OR
FRIENDS OF VIACOM AND ADMIT THAT
WERE NOT OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION WERE LOOKING FOR TO
SPEND SOMETIME WITH THE AUTHOR.
OF AUTHORS AND THEIR STAFF AYE
TO ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS MOST
OF OURS REVOLVES AROUND THREE
THINGS PREEMPTION MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S A PATHWAY.
FOR LOCAL ORDINANCES AND EXITS
NOW TO EITHER FOLD INTO A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF A STATEWIDE PROGRAMS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
UNIFORMITY WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THAT.
NOT TO SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS.
MAKING SURE THAT --
PROGRAM.
FITS THE NEEDS IN THE INTENDED
GOALS --
WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS NO POINT
DOING A PROGRAM IF IT DOESN'T DO
ANYTHING FLANK SHIRT THAT'S
SOMETHING.
I AND THEN LASTLY ON THE COST
PORTION MAKING SURE THAT THERE
ARE GUARDRAILS AROUND.
SOME OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
--
BORN BY STATE DEPARTMENTS OTHER
THAN REIMBURSED BY THE
MANUFACTURERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO TAKE A
PROTECT VERY GOOD I THINK
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS CARLOS
GUTIERREZ I'M WITH THE CONSUMER
HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
WE REPRESENT THE OVER THE
COUNTER MEDICINE MANUFACTURERS
[inaudible]
BUT I'M.
WELL A SIMILAR TO FORMA WERE ON
A NEUTRAL POSITION RIGHT NOW
WITH SOME CONCERNS THEY RELATE
TO PREEMPTION.
OF LOCAL ORDINANCES THE BUT THE
BILL THAT PASSED IN WASHINGTON
AND YORK ALL PREAMP LOCALITIES
SO WE'D LIKE TO MIRROR THAT --
THE CONVENIENCE STANDARD AS
WELL.
AND THE TWO STATES I MENTIONED
BEFORE THEY ALSO HAVE A MUCH
HIGHER CONVENIENCE STANDARD.
AND SIMILAR TO WHAT WAS
SUGGESTED EARLIER WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A BEING MEETING THOSE STANDARDS
WE WOULD LIKE THAT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
STARTING WITH THE ME TOO SECTION
I BELIEVE PETE NO OKAY IF YOU'RE
ANYONE ELSE WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK
FOR A MINUTE OR TWO TO ADDRESS
PARTICULAR CONCERNS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED YET.
AND THEN WE CAN GO TO METERS.
IF I HAD JAMIE MINOR BEHALF THE
ANIMAL HEALTH INS --
TWO WE AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
POINTS YOU KNOW BROUGHT UP IN
THE ANALYSIS THAT ANIMALS MIGHT
NOT ANIMAL USE THAT MIGHT NOT
NECESSARILY BE.
APPROPRIATE --
IN THIS BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS AND THE
COMMITMENTS MADE IN --
ON A PRODUCT THAT WORKS FOR ONE
THING FORGET.
AARON ROBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
GRAIN AND FEED ASSOCIATION IN
JUST BRINGING UP THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES WITH GREEN AND FEED
WE SELL MEDICATED FEED SO WHEN
WE DROP YOU OFF A COUPLE TIMES A
MEDICATED FEED HOW WOULD WE GET
THAT BACK FROM.
THE FROM OUR CLIENT FROM THE
CUSTOMERS SO AGAIN JOINING WITH
THE OF THEIR OPPOSE HOPING FOR
AN EXEMPTION FOR THE ANIMALS
GREAT.
ENGLISH.
GOOD TO HEAR FROM YOU
[inaudible]
UGH.
ALRIGHT ANYONE ELSE WHO WANTS TO
TAKE A MINUTE OR TWO FOR
PARTICULAR CONCERN THEN WE CAN
GO OUT OF ME TEARS THANK YOU --
CALLOUSED ON BEHALF OF WALGREENS
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
SHARE THE SAME CONCERNS THAT
WERE ARTICULATED BY THE
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION LOOK FOR
TO WORK IN THE PROCESS GREAT.
I MEAN ALL TOMORROW BEHALF OF
THE BIOTECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
ORGANIZATION IN OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED POSITION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFERS OVER SUMMER.
JUST A WHOLE FIELD WITH
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE BY A CHAI AND
THINK THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ISSUE
RELATED TO VETERINARY MEDICINE.
AND LIKE CULTURAL OUTLOOK FOR TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHERS
AS BEFORE TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
THANK.
AFTER JASON BRIGHT ON BEHALF
THAT WESTERN AYE DAIRYMAN
REPRESENTING THOUSAND GARY
FAMILY PRODUCERS IN THE STATE
ALSO.
AGNES TURNS OF THE VETERINARIANS
ABOUT HOW THIS WOULD.
IMPACT OR DAIRY PRODUCERS AND
AND HOW WE CAN WORK THAT PROUD
THAT THAT PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD.
DEPARTMENT LOOK FOR THE WORKING
WITH THE WITH THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHORS ON THIS BILL RICHARD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CRISTINA CAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
LIKE TO THANK MISTER TUCKER AND
AND MS JACKSON STAFF FOR WALKING
US THROUGH WHAT WAS.
POTENTIALLY AN AMENDMENT THAT
WOULD HAVE OTHER CAN.
MEDICAL OFFICES A RETAILER WHICH
WAS WORKED OUT WITH THE LEDGE
COUNCIL AMENDMENTS WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO SUPPORT BUT MISTER
TUCKER HAS RAISED ON PAGE TWELVE
REGARDING OF THE EXEMPTION FOR
VETERINARIANS VETERINARY TRUCKS
THANK YOU.
HONORABLE CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
MY NAME SIMPLY BARNETT BUT THE
CENTRAL CONTRA COSTA SANITARY
DISTRICT WE ACTUALLY ARE UNIQUE
BECAUSE WE HAVE PHARMACEUTICAL
COLLECTION BINS THIRTEEN SITES
ON THAT SERVE ABOUT HALF MILLION
CUSTOMERS.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT WE CANNOT
CLICK SHARPS AND WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE IS AN EQUAL ONE
FOR ONE SO NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE
PHARMACEUTICAL WE KNOW THAT NEED
IS THERE.
WE HAVE OF MILLIONS OF POUNDS
THAT ARE COLLECTED --
SINCE THE START OF OUR PROGRAM
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT SHARPS ARE
SOMETHING THAT WE PULL OUT OF
OUR PIPES AND PUMPS.
DALY BECAUSE THOSE WIPES US DOWN
TO SPUR SCHOOLS ARE COLLECTING
THEM SO.
ON WERE REALLY ADVOCATING ON THE
MEAT TO SIDE FOR OUT.
WHO WERE YOU WITH AGAIN?
THE CENTRAL CONTRA COSTA.
STRICT WE ARE THE SO BAY AREA
THANK YOU.
BUT AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUE
STEPHENSON WITH DUBLIN SAN RAMON
SERVICES DISTRICT WHERE WATER
WASTEWATER RECYCLE WATER
PROVIDER.
AND THE GENTLEMAN WHO RUNS OUR
OPERATIONS PLANT. TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN WHEN HE WAS YOUNG OPERATOR
IN THE FIELD HE HAD TO DE RAG A
PUMP REACHED IN AND GOT STUCK.
NOT A PLEASANT THING SO IT'S NOT
JUST PEOPLE WORKING ON HOUSEHOLD
OR THE HAZARDOUS WASTE LINE.
ITS PEOPLE OPERATING SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANTS.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN AND THEY GET
CLOGGED THE POEMS GET CLOGGED SO
WE ALSO ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THOSE SHARPS PROPER DISPOSAL IF
ANYTHING STRENGTHENED THE BILL
PLEASE DON'T DILUTE IT.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANTHONY GONZALEZ REPRESENTING
CITIES OF THOUSAND OAKS IN
TORRANCE AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT --
DO WE HAVE ANY BUT ANY THEIR
WITNESSES.
IF NOT THEN THE AUTHORS IN
MISTER SCHMELZER I CAN COME UP.
AND THEN IF WE HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS THE
REQUIRE SOME OF THE OTHER --
WITNESSES WE CAN BRING THEM UP
THEN -- AND
LET ME SHOW YOU I'M GOING TO ASK
TO BRING THIS SO WHAT I'M GOING
TO ASK THE COMMITTEE TO DO.
IS TO TELL US.
WHAT THEY THINK NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED IN THE BELL?
I'M GOING TO ASK TO BRING IT
BACK IN AUGUST.
AND THEN NOT HAVE A FINAL LOOK
AND YOU CAN VOTE UP OR DOWN NOW
BUT I REALLY WOULD APPRECIATE IF
WE CAN.
MOVE THIS FORWARD NOW SO
WHATEVER YOUR CONCERNS ARE NASTY
TIME TO BRING THEM UP.
SELL OUR MISTER OUT KALRA --
YOU ARE LOOK LIKE YOU HAD YOUR
HAND UP FIRST THING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR --
AND I AM HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL.
OF THANK YOU FOR THE PURPOSES AS
AS YOU STATED.
I'M FOR AND WE NEED A SECOND
SECOND.
YEAH THIS IS A MAJOR UNDERTAKING
THIS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT AND WITH
LOOKED LIKE ANY OTHER MAJOR
UNDERTAKING THERE'S GOING TO BE
A LOT OF FOLKS EXPRESSING
CONCERNS.
COULDN'T CRITICISMS CONSTRUCTIVE
AND OTHERWISE AS WELL AS
SUGGESTIONS AND AND SO I WAS
ACTUALLY WAS GOOD TO HEAR FROM
BOTH SIDES COULD HEAR A LOT OF
FEEDBACK.
ODDS GREAT TO SEE DEPP POKES
ENGAGE THAT AT THE TABLE WILLING
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATIONS
WILLING TO WORK WITH THE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF MY NOSE IN A LOT
OF OF OF GOOD WORK ON THIS --
AND SO RATHER THAN --
AND AND I DO WANT TO THANK YOU
SENATOR UP FOR TAKING ON THIS
MAJOR ENDEAVOR INTO MY ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES AS WELL I THINK IT IS
GOING TO TAKE A NUMBER.
OF FOLKS TO REALLY DO THIS RIGHT
TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE'S CONCERNS
ARE PROPERLY VETTED.
HEARD AND TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
MEDIATED.
ABA BUT THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
THAT -- THIS
IS.
A STATEWIDE PROGRAM IS
ABSOLUTELY NEEDED --
I THINK THAT HAVING DIFFERENT
RULES DIFFERENT CITIES SCOPE
SETTING UP PROGRAMS YOU KNOW
THAT A PROGRAM LIKE THIS IS WHY
WE'RE HERE --
AND SETTING UP A STATEWIDE AND
SO RATHER THAN SUGGESTING WHAT I
THINK MIGHT BE A GOOD.
A MAN MAN OHAD BICU SOUNDS OF
THERE'S ALREADY PLENTY OF
SUGGESTIONS AND WHAT I WOULD BE
MOST INTERESTED IN IS.
IS ASISTIR COMES BACK I MEAN IF
I'M GOING TO BE SITTING HERE I'M
SUBBING IN TODAY BUT I'M
THRILLED IT A BIT IF THE SERVE
WITNESS COMES BACK --
I'M MOST INTERESTED IN HEARING
OF BOTH COMMITTEE STAFF.
THEIR ANALYSIS OF OF A HOUSE THE
ISSUES ARE MITIGATED TO THE BEST
OF SAN POSSIBLE AND AGAIN TO
HEAR FROM BOTH PROPONENTS AND
OPPONENTS HAS TO HAVE.
A LOT OF THE CONCERNS SEEM LIKE
OF THE DOOR ISSUES THAT CAN BE
RESOLVED AND ARE THEN YOU'RE
WORKING ON RESOLVING THEM --
NOW AND SO I I FEEL VERY
ENCOURAGED.
A BASED UPON THE FEEDBACK
POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE THAT THESE
ARE ISSUES THAT THAT WILL BE
RESOLVED IN SO I LOOK FORWARD.
I'M TED.
COMMITTEE.
ABOUT OF THE THEM THAT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE WORK THAT'S
THE BILL IN AUGUST AND WITH HIM
ON THIS COMMITTEE OR IT COMES ON
THE FLOOR.
A BUT I'M CONFIDENT WITH THE
FOOD REVIEW WORKING TOGETHER
CHAIR A COMMITTEE THAT --
WE'RE GONNA MOVE THIS FORWARD
NOTHING IS GONNA BE REALLY GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIANS I CAN ASSURE
YOU MISTER KALRA.
YOU'VE BEEN HERE THROUGH THE
STAFF FORTY FIVE MINUTES YOU
KNOW MORE NOW THAN MOST MEMBERS
DO AND WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR
YOU BACK.
ALRIGHT WHO IT ALRIGHT MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK ANYONE LIGHTER
OUT MATHIS --
I AM HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS TO
MOVE FORWARD TO CONTINUE THE THE
SO -- WORK
IN PROGRESS I WANTED TO KNOW
THAT THEM --
IT IT SEEMS THEIR THE COMEDIAN
ELSE'S HIGHLIGHTS HOW CURRENT
STATE EP ARES INCLUDE CARPET.
PAINT AND MATTRESS AND I KNOW
THAT --
THOSE ISSUES ARE OF VERY
FAMILIAR TO THE A ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
WHICH HAS OVERSIGHT OVER THOSE
ISSUES -- WE
ALSO HAD CONVERSATIONS JUST
YESTERDAY ABOUT.
TO A BILL RELATED --
TO THE LATEST EFFORT TO OUR
ADDRESS ANOTHER CHALLENGING AIR
AREA WHICH IS TO UPDATE THE
BOTTLE BILL.
AND THE THE CHALLENGES OF THE
THE LACK OF RECYCLING CENTERS.
AND THE THAT THAT THE CHALLENGE
OF HOW TO MAKE.
THE COLLECTIONS ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE BY MAKING THEM --
THAT THEM THEM --
MOST CONVENIENT AND ACCESSIBLE
AND SO ON YEAH I I WOULD LIKE --
TO YOU TO BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS IN AND AND TRY TO BRING
IN THE THE EXPERTISE OF THE THAT
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE ARE
AND THEIR EXPERIENCE OF THESE
PROGRAMS [inaudible] TWO WELL.
TO TRY [inaudible]
TO MAKE THIS.
THE BEST PROGRAM AGAIN HALF OUR
STATE.
I WILL CERTAINLY.
BE GLAD IF YOU CAN LEARN THE
SOME OF YOUR STAFF INFANT DOT TO
HELP WITH THIS.
AND YOU WERE ALSO GOING TO BE
ASKING THAT SANITY Q. AND
PERHAPS THAT HEALTH COMMITTEES
--
TODD TOGETHER SAID THEIR INPUT
AS WELL BECAUSE THE SENATE
HASN'T SEEN THIS BILL AT ALL SO
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THERE COMMITTEES ARE.
WORK WITH US ON THIS UNDER UP
LEADERSHIP OF MY CHIEF
CONSULTANT ARE MISTER TUCKER.
SO WE WILL DEFINITELY AVAIL
OURSELVES OF ANY EXPERTISE YOU
HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A MISTER A MATHIS THEY YOU
MISTER CHAIR FIRST SENATOR AND
COLLEAGUES --
IN HERE.
UNDERGOING SOMETHING THAT DEFTLY
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN OUR STATE AND
HAVE A STATEWIDE.
PROGRAM IS.
SOMETHING WE VITALLY NEEDED
ESPECIALLY KNOW ON THE SERVER IN
OUR RURAL AREAS.
THAT WE HAVE --
IN IN HAVING THE CONCERNS
[inaudible]
ARE.
YEAH IT'S A A SET ON A NATIONAL
LEGISLATIVE WORK FOR AG AND
RURAL.
LIKE COMMUNITIES AND YOU KNOW
THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC SOME THAT WE
TALK ABOUT THEIR ON THE AND I
KNOW THEY'RE LOOKING AT WHAT'S
GOING ON OF THIS LEGISLATION
[inaudible]
TO SHELL.
I I DO HAVE SOME CURRENT
CONCERNS ARE MENTIONED EARLIER
--
WITH THE AG INDUSTRY GUYS.
ON WITH THE VETERINARY CONCERN
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT THE
AIM OF THIS BILL.
WAS TO GO LAUGHTER VETERINARY
SIDE I THINK WE'RE LOOKING MORE
FOR THE HOUSEHOLD IN IN THE KIDS
AT PARTIES AND DOING THOSE
THINGS ARE MAKING SURE WE CAN
GET THOSE OFF THE STREETS --
SOME REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU SEE IN
IN THE CONVERSATION THAT.
YOU KNOW IT IN EXPRESSLY --
SENATOR I KNOW YOU LIKE TO GET
EVERYBODY TOGETHER IN A ROOM CAN
HASH THINGS OUT AND GET IT DONE
AND I APPRECIATE YOU --
TREMENDOUSLY FOR THAT SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT WE'RE
LIKE A MONTH WITH OVER THE
SUMMER.
I KNOW --
SPEAKING WITH A LOT OF THE OTHER
RURAL GUYS YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL
KIND OF ENCOURAGES SEE SOMETHING
HAPPEN BUT YOU GOTTA MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S THE RIGHT THING SO.
BUT ALL IT WITH THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
YEAH CERTAINLY THIS IS A COMPLEX
ISSUE AND I'M THANK YOU FOR
TAKING IT ON A GOOD JUST COUPLE
REALLY QUICK QUESTIONS DO WE
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MUCH THE
STEWARDSHIP PROGRAMS ARE GOING
TO COST.
WELL WE DO KNOW THAT --
THAT THERE'S BEEN AN ACTIVE
PROGRAM UP IN A BRITISH COLUMBIA
FOR ABOUT TWENTY YEARS THAT
IRONICALLY WAS SET UP BY THE
INDUSTRY ITSELF.
AND THE COST RUNS AT ABOUT ONE
TENTH OF ONE CENT FOR EACH
PRESCRIPTION.
SO THE ITSO MINIMAL COST
[inaudible]
AND SO I'D IT YOU'RE TRYING TO
FOLLOW THEIR THEIR THEIR
PROGRAMMING WELL IF IF THEY'RE
CERTAINLY A GUIDE POST --
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE WELL
OBVIOUSLY WE'LL DO OUR OWN
PROGRAM BUT BECAUSE THERE'S SOME
QUESTIONS THEY INCINERATE THEIR
PRODUCTS IN THERE MIGHT BE
DIFFERENCES IN.
IN THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT BUT IT'S WE WANT TO KEEP.
OKAY.
AND DOES THE BILL HAVE ANY
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD THAT ARE
GOING TO HELP THE A SHARPS
DISPOSAL BY PEOPLE WITH DRUG
ADDICTIONS AND THE HOMELESS.
I WE WE HEAR THE STORIES IN SAN
FRANCISCO ABOUT THE NEEDLES
BEING ON ON THE SIDEWALK AND SO
FORTH AND DOES THIS BILL HELP
ADDRESS STEP.
VERY SPECIFIC PROBLEM.
THAT'S ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I GOT INVOLVED IN
THIS ISSUE ON THE SHARP SIDE.
ARM. ONE THING AND AS I BELIEVE.
MISTER MISS MISTER KALRA TALKED
ABOUT IS JUST MAKING EVERYTHING
MORE CONVENIENT AND THAT'S
REALLY.
WHY WE'RE TRYING TO ESTABLISH%
SORT OF ZONES AND AREAS WHERE?
CAN KNOW WHERE TO DISPOSE OF
THAT'S I THINK THE HOPE IS THAT
ONCE PEOPLE KNOW WHERE THEY CAN
GO THEY WILL DO IT.
NOW AGAIN YOU HAVE SOME FOLKS
WHO HAVE.
I TIMES VERY SERIOUS ISSUES SO
THING THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE UP
HUMPED TEMPERATURES PATIENT BUT
THE HOPE IS THAT THE MORE
CONVENIENT WE CAN MAKE. FOR
EVERYBODY THAT --
FOLKS WALK RESPONSIBLY.
OKAY.
WELL.
I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN REACH A
POLICY THAT ADDRESSES MORE THE
STAKEHOLDER CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD
A NUMBER OF THEM ALREADY.
AND I'M NOT QUITE THERE BUT I'M
HOPING THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
THOSE THINGS WORK IN THE SUMMER
SO ONE AGAINST THE FOR THE LIKE
SPORT MAKE IT [inaudible]
OKAY.
A DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
I'M NOT START MY COMMENTS BY
THINKING THE AUTHORS FOR
BRINGING THIS TO A NECESSARY --
BILL FORWARD IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS HAD ON
I AM GONNA.
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT PROCESS
THOUGH AND I HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF DOT CONCERNS BASED ON WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS TODAY I'M WILLING
TO ALLOW THIS TO GO FORWARD.
BUT WANTS TO MAKE SURE THE
VOICES OF OUR AD COMMUNITY IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE HURT.
THAT THIS ONE SIZE FITS ALL
POLICY DOES NOT.
OVERLY HURT AN INDUSTRY THAT'S
THIS CITY HAS NOT ALWAYS BEEN TO
KIND TWO AND SO WOULD WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY POLICIES WE
PUSH OUT.
ARE RECOGNIZING THAT AND TAKING
CARE OF OUR AG COMMUNITIES.
I'M SPECIFICALLY LOOKING AT BOTH
THE MEDICATED FEED ON THE
VETERINARY MEDICINE PORTIONS
THIS.
SECONDARILY I UNDERSTAND THE
LOGIC BETWEEN TRYING --
TO COMBINING STATEWIDE POLL --
BUT THEY'RE NOT UBIQUITOUS AND
SOME OF THE CONCERNS I HAVE ARE
STEMMING FROM WHAT OCCURS WITHIN
A HOSPITAL SO I'D.
LIKE SOME UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT
HAPPENS IN MORE CLINIC SETTINGS
WHAT HAPPENS IN MORE RURAL
SETTINGS HOW DOES THIS ACTUALLY
GET IMPLEMENTED AND SO --
THERE MAY BE A PLENTY OF TIME
FOR US TO DISCUSS WITH THIS BUT
IN LIGHT OF THE PROCESS THAT I
STARTED WITH THIS I'D LIKE AN
OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHORS TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL.
AND MAKE SURE THIS IS THE BEST
POLICY THAT WE CAN PUSH FORWARD.
BOMB YOU KNOW THE ENEMY A
PERFECT SHOULD NOT BE GOOD AND I
DON'T INTEND TO STOP THIS IN ITS
TRACKS BUT WANT US TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PUT IT.
BEST POLICY FORWARD AND I
BELIEVE THAT'S TAKING AND WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM STAKEHOLDERS
AND I IMPROVING UPON THIS AND
HOPE THAT'S WHAT COMES BACK IN
AUGUST --
BUT THERE ARE CONCERNS OF BOTH
FROM THOSE OF US WHO ARE GOING
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY A WHO WANTS
TO MAKE SURE THIS IS A BETTER
PRODUCT GOING FORWARD
[inaudible]
TOTALLY AGREE.
ALRIGHT ARE PERHAPS YOU WOULD.
LIKE DID THE AUTHORS THEN --
COULD DE BRIEFLY I KNOW YOU HAVE
TO GET OFF TO CHAIR YOU'RE A
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND YOU HAVE
SIXTY TWO BILLS. THREE SIXTY
THREE SO I KNOW YOU'D LIKE TO
GET THAT OFF SO.
APPROACH YOU COULD DO THE THREE
OF YOU COULD CLOSE QUICKLY AND
THAT WILL GET ON TO THE NEXT
MATTER --
THANK YOU AN AND DOES THIS THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO GET.
SOMETHING GOING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME I WON'T REFERRED WOOD IS
SORT OF A FORM OF RELUCTANCE ON
EVERYBODY'S PART.
EVERYBODY'S AT THE TABLE NOW
THAT HAS BEEN THE BIGGEST
CHALLENGE WE'VE HAD IS TO GET
EVERYBODY TO SIT DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT THIS.
THERE THERE THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT IT.
HAPPEN FRANKLY SORT RECENTLY AND
AS A RESULT OF THERE ARE LOTS OF
VERY GOOD POINTS AND I THINK AN
OPEN AND HONEST AND FRANK
DISCUSSION.
IS WHAT WE FINALLY ARE GETTING
AND I THINK WE'RE ALL COMMITTED
TO RESPONDING --
AND TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED AND BY ALLOWING
US TO CONTINUE IN THIS PROCESS I
THINK WE ARE.
A BY OPENING THAT DOOR.
OUR BUDDY 80% OF THE WAY THERE
IT WAS JUST GETTING THAT DOOR
OPEN THAT'S BEEN REALLY THE
CHALLENGE AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS THERE
WE ARE GOING TO BE ABLE --
TO COME TO A A GOOD RESOLUTION
AND TO WITH THAT I WOULD SIMPLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
OKAY.
BECAUSE I REMEMBER TENGAN GRAY
OKAY -- SO
LET ME -- I
THINK I HEARD FROM SEVERAL
MEMBERS THAT THERE SHOULD BE A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM.
NOW I THINK IT SHOULD ONLY BE A
STATE WIDE PROGRAM IF IT'S
BETTER THAN ALL THE LOCAL
PROGRAMS.
I THINK IF WE CAN DO THAT THEN
WE CAN BRING PEOPLE ALONG TO
MAKE IT A STATE WIDE PROGRAM BUT
IT REALLY HAS TO BE BETTER --
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY PROGRAM THE FIRST
ONE IN THE STATE --
I FOLLOWED IT WHEN IT WAS
LEGISLATION I FOLLOWED IT IN THE
COURT CASE BUT THEN I NEVER
HEARD ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THEY
HAVE A PROGRAM.
NOBODY IN HAYWARD KNOWS THE
COLLECTION SITES ARE IN OBSCURE
PLACES THIS FORTY ONE THE COUNTY
BUT THERE TYPICALLY AT VERY
SMALL.
SORT OF MOM AND POP PHARMACIES
--
THAT OCCASIONALLY --
KAISER AS TAKEN ABACK WHICH IS A
MAJOR THING BECAUSE HALF THE
PEOPLE PROBABLY TO USE KAISER.
BUT FOR ANYONE WHO ISN'T USING
KAISER.
THEY DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
PROGRAM --
IN MY OPINION WE SHOULD HAVE
EVERY PHARMACY VIEW PART OF DRUG
TAKE BACK.
SHARP SHOULD CLEARLY DIFFERENT I
DON'T THINK THE SHARPS PART OF
THIS PROGRAM IS MATURE YET.
IT IS HARD TO GET BILLS OFF THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR AND IF THE SHARPS
PART IS NOT BETTER IT IT RISKS.
BRINGING DOWN THE WHOLE BILL SO
YOU MAY WANT TO THINK ABOUT
MAKING THE SHARPS PART SEPARATE
IN NEGOTIATING THAT SEPARATE.
ARE BUT I THINK THE DRUGS PART
IF WE CAN MAKE IT EFFECTIVE AND
AGAIN I HEARD THAT FROM A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE.
HERE IN THE WITNESSES WE HAVE TO
MAKE IT EFFECTIVE I REALLY THINK
THAT MEANS EVERY PHARMACY.
HAS A BOX OF SOME KIND A LOCK
BOX THAT TAKES THE DRUGS.
ARM THAT THE PHARMACIST SAID HEY
IF YOU DON'T FINISH ALL OF THIS
BRING IT BACK.
I THINK THAT'S THE ONLY WAY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A REALLY
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM I'M WILLING TO
LISTEN TO OTHER WAYS.
BUT AGAIN.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PROGRAM
WHICH TO MY MIND IT SHOULD BE
STATEWIDE AND BETTER THAN ANY OF
THE LOCAL PROGRAMS --
ON THE VETERINARY SIDE A BILL
CAN BE KILLED BY THE PEOPLE FROM
OUR RURAL AREAS I KNOW THIS FOR
A FACT.
ARM AND SO I AYE YEAH EXACTLY
EXACTLY.
HE IS ONE OF THE CULPRITS ARE
MISTER GRAY --
SHALL I WOULD BE VERY CAREFUL
ABOUT THE VETERINARY PROGRAM --
PARTICULARLY MEDICATED FEED BY
AND LARGE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
USE THAT FEEDS I DON'T THINK
THEY THINK THEY CAN JUST STORED
ON SITE AS LONG AS IT'S NOT
GETTING IN THE WATERS.
IT SHOULD BE FINE AND ANYWAY TRY
AND MAKE IT AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
--
LET'S SEE --
THING ELSE.
ALRIGHT SO --
I KNOW YOU'VE AGREED TO WORK
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS ARE
WITH THAT JOSH WILL BE WORKING
WITH YOU S. THAT.
CHIEF ARE CONSULTANT BUT WILL BE
BRINGING IN CONSULTANTS FROM.
OUR NATURAL RESOURCES AS WELL AS
A SANITY Q. AND PROBABLY HEALTH
AND OTHERS WHO WANT TO GET
INVOLVED --
SO WE REALLY WANT A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM WE REALLY WANT THIS DONE
AND I HOPE.
THAT IN AUGUST WE HAVE A BILL
THAT JOB WILL WILL GO THROUGH
THE ASSEMBLY AND THEN THE SENATE
BE SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
GONNA HAVE A VOTE. OH YES
NOTHING LIKE A VOTE.
GUY HAD MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS SP TWO TWELVE JACKSON
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
I QUIRK AYE MATHIS.
NOW VOTING MATHIS IS NOT VOTING
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA AYE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I'M [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY IS IN NO [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
NOT TO CHEAT.
WHAT A TO G. --
THREE I FEDERAL YET ANOTHER TWO
BEFORE THE DAY'S OUT THANK YOU
SENATOR.
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
.
THANK YOU BUT NO HAN BUT I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING OUT.
YOU KNOW HERE.
SO.
HE KNOWS OUR FIRST.
YEAR.
HERE BECAUSE IT'S NOT
[inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible] THREE IT IS THE
YEAH WELL GET THIS.
DONE.
WELL STARTED SOON AS EVERYONE WE
ALRIGHT SENATOR HILL IS
PRESENTING.
ACTUALLY LET ME DO THE YOM Y.
HAVE FOUR MEMBERS LET ME DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
YOU WANT ME.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS S. B.
TEN FIFTY FOUR HERTZBERG AND SB
ELEVEN THIRTY THREE PORTANTINO.
AND THEY'RE BOTH DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS --
OR THE RECOMMENDATION OF
CONSENT.
SO QUIRK I QUIRK IS AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE ARAMBULA [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
WHAT A TO G. WHEN ATTENTION TO
THAT'S PASSES OUT FOR VOTES?
INCENDIARY GOOD SENATOR HILL
YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT ON S. B.
ONE FOUR EIGHT ONE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR S. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE IS THE SUNSET BILL
FOR THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
BOARD.
THIS BILL MAKES VARIOUS CHANGES
TO THE STRUCTURAL PEST CONTROL
ACT INTENDED TO IMPROVE
OVERSIGHT.
BY THE BOARD AND EXTENDS THE
OPERATIONS OF THE BOARD UNTIL
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
THREE THE CHAMBER OF THE BILL
ARE RESULT OF THE DISCUSSIONS
DURING THE POWER TO THAT S.
RIVAL MEMBERS THINK THEY ARE
RIGHT I'M SURE YOU HAVE FOUR
VOTES.
I THEIR I AM SUSAN TAYLOR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAN ANSWER
SINCE THE OTHER THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR OF ITS OCCUPANTS
KEYBOARD.
I'M OF COURSE WERE IN SUPPORT OF
JOINING THE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CAN ANSWER
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE A ALRIGHT
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
BRADFORD AYE VOTE MEMBERS ARE I
THINK.
ARE RECOMMENDING AND AYE AND
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
HILL.
STE YOU PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I HOLDEN.
WHAT IT TOO CHEAP?
GRETA JACK WE HAVE FOUR VOTES
THAT'S OUT.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU MEMBERS IF THEY COULD ALL BE
THIS EASY [inaudible]
BUT JENNIFER DOT.
THIS IS S. B..
NINE SENATOR DODD IS PRESENTING
ON S. B..
NINE NINE EIGHT I HAD THIS
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS S. B. NINE NINE
EIGHT WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S.
POLICY ON THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER IS ACHIEVED.
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE MORE
STRINGENT WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS IN THE EFFECTS OF
WATER CONSERVATION ON REVENUE.
PUSH WATER COSTS AND REGINALD
RESIDENTIAL WATER RATES HIGHER
AND HIGHER.
MORE THAN FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE'S
ELEVENTH LARGEST WATER UTILITIES
ARE IMPACTED BY AFFORDABILITY
COSTS OF LIVING ISSUES.
SAN DIEGO SIX THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS ALONE FAYSAL THE LOTS
OF WATER SERVICE.
DUE TO DELINQUENT BILLS EACH
YEAR.
WHILE THERE CAN CONSISTENT
LIFELINE PROGRAMS FOR PEOPLE
HAVING DIFFICULTY PAYING THEIR
ELECTRIC GAS AND TELEPHONE
BILLS.
THEIR ONLY A PATCHWORK OF LOCAL
POLICIES FOR WATER BILL
DELINQUENCIES.
S. B. NINE NINE EIGHT SIX TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS.
WHO FACE TERMINATION OF THEIR
WATER SERVICE IN THE FOLLOWING
WAYS?
IT REQUIRES PUBLISHED WATER
AGENCY POLICIES FOR DEFERRED
PAYMENTS ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PLANS IT APPEALS.
IT REQUIRES WAITING PERIODS
BEFORE TERMINATING SERVICE IN
REQUIREMENTS FOR CONTACTING THE
REPAIR.
IT LIMITS DISK INTO A
CONTINUATION IN THE EVENT OF A
LIFE AND HEALTH SAFETY PROBLEMS
WERE SEVERE ECONOMIC HARDSHIP.
PROVIDED THAT THE RATE PAYER
COMPLIES WITH CERTAIN
CONDITIONS.
THE BILL LIMITS FEES FOR
RECONNECTING SERVICE FOR LOW
INCOME WATER.
A LOW INCOME RATEPAYERS.
AND I HAVE A LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
OPINION THAT S. B. NINE NINE
EIGHT DOES NOT CREATE.
A PROP TO EIGHTEEN CONFLICT IT
MAKES CLEAR THAT THE WATER
AGENCY CAN'T EVENTUALLY COLLECT
ON RAPIER DEBT THINK THAT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT HERE.
THAT IT DOES NOT CREATE A PROP
TO EIGHTEEN CONFLICT AND MAKES
IT VERY CLEAR THAT THE WATER
AGENCY CAN EVENTUALLY COLLECT ON
THE RATEPAYERS DEBT.
THE BILL SUPPORTED BY MANY
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN A
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU RIGHT
[inaudible]
WITNESSES.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRAIL IF MEMBER
TWO MINUTES EACH.
MY NAME IS ALEXANDER HERNDON A
HOUSING ADVOCATE WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR S. B.. NINE NINE
EIGHT FOR THE LOW INCOME AND
VULNERABLE TENANTS THAT WE
REPRESENT A WATER SHUT OFF CAN
HAVE DIRE CONSEQUENCE FOR EVERY
ASPECT OF THEIR LIVES.
YOU CAN THREATEN PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL HEALTH FOOD SECURITY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT HOUSING
SUBSIDIES FAMILY AND COMMUNITY
COHESION AND THE ABILITY TO GET
AND MAINTAIN A JOB.
AS A LEGAL AID ATTORNEY IN LOS
ANGELES I REPRESENTED A LOW
INCOME MOTHER OF THREE WHO'S
WATER WAS SHUT OFF WHEN HER
LANDLORD FAILED TO PAY THE BILL
FOR HER ENTIRE APARTMENT
BUILDING.
SPIKE CONTINUING TO CHARGE
TENANTS MONTHLY FOR THEIR WATER
USE.
IN ATTEMPTING TO RESOLVE THE
SITUATION WITH HER LANDLORD --
OR WHILE SHE WAS ATTEMPTING TO
RESOLVE THE SITUATION WITH HER
LANDLORD AND FORCE HER HOUSING
RIGHTS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES BEGAN
THREATENING TO REMOVE HER
CHILDREN FROM HER HOME DUE TO
THE LACK OF RUNNING WATER.
I'M AND SO EVENTUALLY FORCED TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN ENFORCING THOSE
HOUSING RIGHTS.
AND PROTECTING YOUR FAMILY
SAFETY SHE ABANDONED HER HOUSING
AND WAS FORCED TO MOVE OUT AND
OFTEN THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT THESE LOW INCOME
RENTERS A LACK SUBSTANTIAL
CONTROL OVER THE SITUATION THAT
LEAD TO A SHUT OFF EITHER
BECAUSE THE LANDLORD IS THE ONE
WHO HAS THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
ACTUALLY.
PAY THE WATER BILL --
OR BECAUSE THEY'RE ABILITY TO
REPAIR INFRASTRUCTURE OF A A
WATER LEAK THAT CAN LEAD TO A
VERY HIGH BILL --
OR IN AND VERY IMPORTANT
SITUATIONS A SHUT OFF CAN LEAD
THAT CAN RESULT FROM A
DESTRUCTIVE LIFE EVENT LIKE A
DISEASE OR A LOSS OF OF A JOB
THAT THAT LEADS TO AN ECONOMIC
DISRUPTION --
SO S. B. NINE NINE EIGHT TAKES
AN IMPORTANT STEP. TO MAKING THE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATER A REALITY FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT AND
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEBBIE OR
SOME STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER.
A COMMUTER CENTER WAS ONE OF THE
STE A LEAD SUPPORTERS WHEN THEY
WHEN THE STATE WAS TRY TO PASS A
HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER LEGISLATION
BACK IN.
TWENTY TWELVE S. B. NINE NINE
EIGHT IS A NECESSARY TOOL IN OUR
STATES TOOLBOX AS WERE
ATTEMPTING TO ACTUALLY REALIZE
HUMAN RIGHTS WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
THE FBI NAY NAY WILL PROVIDE
PREPARE PROTECTIONS FOR WATER
UTILITY CUSTOMERS THAT ALREADY
EXIST FOR AT FOR MANY ENERGY
UTILITIES.
A WHILE WE AGREE THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD PAY THEIR BILL IN TIME
AND ON FOR IN FULL THERE.
ARE SITUATIONS WHERE.
LIFE COMES UP AND YOU CANNOT PAY
YOUR BILL THAT FOR A MOMENT --
SETTING UP CLEAR TRANSPARENT
POLICIES ON HOW --
WATER DISCONTINUATION OCCURS
ALLOWS CUSTOMERS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE AND WHAT
THEIR OPTIONS ARE TO PREVENT
DISCONTINUATION SERVICE AND HOW
THEY CAN PAY THEIR BILLS WHEN
THEY'RE ABLE --
TO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO
HAVE AND IT WILL HELP PREVENT.
A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACTS TO VOTER POPULATION SUCH
AS THOSE WITH MEDICAL CONDITIONS
WHO WOULD BE GREATLY EXACERBATED
OR HAVE LIFE THREATENING IMPACTS
IF WATER WAS CUT OFF.
OR FOR INFANTS AND CHILDREN
WHICH I THINK WE ALL AGREE
SHOULD NOT BE --
LET WITH HOT WATER.
EVERY CONSUMER THE RIGHT
UNDERSTAND AND THIS IS WHY WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
THANK YOU BOB OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
NICHOLAS CHVEZ ON BEHALF THE
GOING STATE MANUFACTURED
HOMEOWNERSHIP ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING SENIORS VETERANS
IMMIGRANTS AND LOW MODERATE AND
FIXED INCOME INDIVIDUALS LIVING
IN MOBILE HOME PARKS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
ON SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE EIGHT
THANK YOU.
HE BE SEEN LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE FOR THE LOCAL
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND SERIES IN SUPPORT.
REBECCA MARKETS REPRESENTING
FOOD AND WATER WATCH IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
AND YOU MEANS FISHER WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS A
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT.
ARM.
CHAU I HAD A MEETING YESTERDAY
--
WITH THE LOCAL WATER COMPANIES
WHO I KNOW ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE HAVE WATER BUT I
KNOW THEY HAVE SPECIFIC CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL.
AND IF I COULD HAVE --
I REPRESENTATIVES OUT FOR IN
OPPOSITION NOW.
AGAIN THESE PEOPLE ARE FOR
MAKING SURE PEOPLE HAVE WIDER
THEY JUST HAVE PARTICULAR
CONCERNS.
GUY HAD GOOD AFTER GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN QUIRK AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
WENDY RITTER BUSH WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ARE AQUA.
AND A AS YOU NOTED OUR MEMBER
AGENCIES DELIVER SAFE RELIABLE
HIGH QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
WATER TO CUSTOMERS IN A
DEPENDABLE AND RESPONSIBLE
MANNER.
PUBLIC WATER DISTRICTS ARE
OVERSEEN BY THEIR LOCALLY
ELECTED BOARDS OF DIRECTORS THEY
MAKE DECISIONS IN THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC SERVICE TERRITORIES
BASED ON WHAT WORKS LOCALLY.
WATER AGENCIES ARE IN THE
BUSINESS OF DELIVERING WATER
THEY DON'T DISCONNECT DELINQUENT
CUSTOMERS WITHOUT PRIOR
SUBSTANTIAL ENGAGEMENT.
WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN HIS STAFF LESS BOND
FOR ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE THAT AMONG OTHER THINGS
DELETED LANGUAGE WHICH WOULD
HAVE REQUIRED THAT A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER.
MAKE A PHYSICAL VISIT TO
DETERMINE THAT A WATER SHUT OFF
EVEN A TEMPORARY ONE WOULD NOT
POSE A GRAVE THREAT TO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
OF A CUSTOMER PRIOR TO A SHUT
OFF.
AND UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THE
GOOD FAITH EFFORTS INCLUDING
SEVERAL MEETINGS BETWEEN THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND OUR
COALITION.
I COME TO AGREEMENT ON THE
BILL'S LANGUAGE THEY'RE STILL
REMAIN IMPORTANT AMENDMENTS THAT
WE HAVE CRAFTED WE REQUESTED
WHICH HAVE BEEN REJECTED TODAY
AND THESE INCLUDE THE ISSUES OF
RECONNECT GEN FEES AND COST
SHIFTING.
AND AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE AUTHOR HAS
RECEIVED ALLEGE COUNSEL OPINION
ON A VERY SPECIFIC SLICE OF THE
BILL.
THE OPINION DISCUSSES ONE
SECTION. SIX NINE A EIGHT WHICH
DETAILS NEW RESTRICTIONS ON DIS
CONNECTIONS OF WATER SERVICE FOR
NON PAYMENT.
WITH THE OPINION DOES NOT DO IS
WAY EN ON THE APPLICABILITY OF
PROP TWO EIGHTEEN TO HELP AND
KIDS SAFETY CODE SECTION ONE ONE
SIX NINE ONE TWO WHICH APPEARS
LATER IN THE BILL AND CREATES A
CAP ON THE FEES. FOR THE COST OF
PHYSICALLY RECONNECTING WATER
SERVICE FOR CUSTOMERS WHO ARE
NOT BELOW THE 2100% FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE IT ALSO WAVES THE
RECONNECTION FEES ALTOGETHER FOR
THOSE UNDER THE LINE.
OUR CONCERN IS WHAT WOULD OCCUR
WHEN THIS ARBITRARY CAP ON THE
RE CONNECTIONS FEET IS BELOW THE
ACTUAL COST OF SERVICE IF YOU
COULD DAM.
I I THINK YOUR POINT IS MADE AND
YOU HAVE SIX SECONDS YEAH
ACTUALLY SIX SECONDS LATTER
MACON AND DEATH IF.
ASSUMING THAT THE OTHER WITNESS
WANTS TO MANAGE YES.
I'M I WILL DISCLOSE THAT --
WE CARE ABOUT AFFORDABILITY WE
CARE ABOUT OUR CUSTOMERS.
I AND WHAT WE WANT TO SEE IS WE
WANT TO SEE A WATER SERVICE SHUT
OFF UP PROVISION AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHERE THE LOCALS ARE
REALLY.
THE BEST PLACE TO DECIDE ON HOW
TO DO THAT AND HOW DID YOU THAT
BEST IN THEIR AREAS THANK YOU.
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S UP WITH
CALIFORNIA'S FOR UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND WE ALSO MUST
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSE SB NINE
NINE EIGHT AS MY COLLEAGUE NOTED
YOU KNOW SENIOR WAYS MEMBER
AGENCIES CARE ABOUT THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
THE INTENT OF THE OF THE
POLICIES THAT WE HAVE GOVERNING
SHUT OFFS IS TO ENSURE THAT
WATER SERVICES DISCONTINUED FOR
NON PAYMENT.
ONLY WHEN A CUSTOMER FAILS TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH MULTIPLE
SAFEGUARDS BUILT INTO THE
OPERATION AND MANAGEMENT OF
WATER SYSTEMS THAT WERE
CONCERNED THAT THE TOP DOWN
APPROACH IN S. B. NINE NINE
EIGHT IS REALLY A SOLUTION IN
SEARCH OF A PROBLEM.
THERE'S CURRENTLY NO WIDESPREAD
DATA THAT SUPPORTS THE ASSERTION
THAT LARGE SWATHS OF LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS ARE HAVING THEIR
WATERSHED OFF FOR NON PAYMENT OR
INABILITY TO PAY.
IN ADDITION WHILE THE HUMAN
RIGHTS WATER HAS BEEN REFERENCE
TO IT BY SUPPORTERS HIS
REASONING FOR THE SPELL AND WE
FEEL THAT'S IMPORTANT AS WELL.
THAT STATUTE CONTAINS LESS
PUBLIC IT SAYS.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
SECTION SHALL NOT INFRINGE ON
THE RIGHTS RESPONSIBILITIES OF
ANY PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM.
AND THE LANGUAGE IN S. B. NINE
AND A CURRENTLY INFRINGES ON
THOSE RIGHTS AND
RESPONSIBILITIES BY FORCING AND
YOU COST SHIFTING FROM ONE SET
OF CUSTOMERS TO THE OTHER.
OR TO ANOTHER SET PARTICULARLY
THE ARBITRARY CAP ON
RECONNECTION FEES.
WE BELIEVE THERE'S EXISTING
STATUTE RELATED TO THIS ISSUE IN
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE THAT
GOVERNS BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
WATER SYSTEMS WE BELIEVE THAT IF
CHANGES NEED TO BE MADE. TO
ADDRESS POTENTIAL ISSUES WE
SHOULD USE THE EXISTING
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK AND WE URGE
A NO VOTE.
ALL RIGHT OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON ROUND TO ROSSI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION POSITION
THANK YOU.
RENTS ARE SOCKS BUT LOCAL GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE MODESTO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND LONG
BEACH WATER DEPARTMENT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
AARON EVANS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ALSO
IN OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROSANNA CARACCIOLI HERE
ON BEHALF OF TIE WATER DISTRICT
AND MISSION SPRINGS WATER
DISTRICT ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON STEPHANIE MORAL
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL WATER
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION.
IF YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RUN
DAVIS ON BEHALF OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON BETH ALAS ON
BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTIE Y.
BEHALF OF THE THREE VALLEY'S
MISCIBLE WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARINO HERON ON BEHALF
OF THE IRVINE RANCH WATER
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY OCWEN CMU I
THINK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANTHONY CAN SOLVE US
REPRESENTING THE CITIES OF
THOUSAND OAKS LIKE WHAT ROSE
FELL.
AND THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY WATER
SUCH ASIAN OPPOSE THANK YOU.
AND JENNIFER COMPUTER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ARM.
QUESTIONS FROM ANY OF THE
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YES --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI THANK
YOU ETCETERA I INDICATED TO YOU
THAT NOW THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING --
YOUR BILL ARE AND I WILL.
VOTE FOR A BELT FOR TODAY --
BUT I LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY OF
HEARING SOME CONCERN SAID IT
COULD YOU DRESS LIKE.
ONE WHY --
STATEWIDE --
POLICY SHOULD BE ENACTED RATHER
THAN -- A
LOCAL POLICIES INTO PA IF IT IF
THERE ARE --
CAPS PLACED ON LIKE BE
RECONNECTION FEES.
WHO'S GONNA PAY --
FOR THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
CAPS AND THE ACTUAL COST OF
RECONNECTING WATER SERVICE WELL
TO THE TO DO THAT TO THE FIRST
QUESTION --
I BELIEVE.
WHAT I'VE SEEN THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT?
YEAH I'VE HEARD FROM OTHERS
THROUGHOUT NIGHT YOU KNOW MATCH
AND SAN DIEGO I HAD I WAS TRYING
TO KEEP BY.
TALKING POINTS SHORT BUT THE I
COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT SAID
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE --
FEEL FREE TO GO ON AND ON GREAT
--
I SAID MORT BY PIPE. FOR FIVE
POINT FIVE FEET MILLION PEOPLE
IN THE STATE'S UP ELEVEN LARGEST
WATER UTILITIES.
ARE IMPACTED BY WATER
AFFORDABILITY RIGHT NOW OUR
OTHER UTILITIES POWER AND GAS
AND PHONE HAVE LIFELINE RATES
THAT ARE.
DONE BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
--
A ED CHIU OFTEN PARTICULAR ONE
ONE COMMUNITY IN LAKE COUNTY
RIGHT NOW WHICH IS.
WHICH IS ON FIRE WE HAVE IT'S
NOT A MATTER OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
[inaudible]
ARE --
YELLOW LOSE THEIR WATER IT'S
WHO.
AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE THAT ARE A
ELDERLY THERE ON A HOSPICE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE YOUNG CHILDREN
--
THAT DID NEED SUPPORT AND WHILE
THESE ORGANIZATIONS MORE THAN
LIKELY TAKEN AT THEIR WORD
THEY'RE ALL GOOD PEOPLE SOLID
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT THEY REPRESENT --
THEIR MEMBERS PERHAPS DUE BUT
NOT ALL.
WATER PURVEYORS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE ANY
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES.
IN THIS REGARD AND THIS IS WHY
IT'S NECESSARY I I WOULD AGREE.
ONLY TO THE FACT THAT --
YA ON THAT CAP I'M WILLING TO
WORK WITH THE YOU KNOW THE
OPPONENTS ON THIS AS WE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD --
BECAUSE THAT WAS KIND OF NEW TO
ME ABOUT THE PROP.
TWO EIGHTEEN PROVISION AS IT
APPLIES TO JUST THAT NARROW.
I INTERESTS AND SO.
AB THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD --
I WOULD BE MORE THAN HAPPY --
TO HERE TO DO YOU KNOW TO WORK
WITH THEM ON THAT GOING.
FOR I THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
I ANYONE ELSE.
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SPEC WE ASK DR VOTE OKAY
[inaudible]
SO -- FIRST
OF ALL I DO THINK IT'S NECESSARY
TO HAVE A FLOOR.
AND AS THE AUTHOR SAID I BELIEVE
THAT THE ORGANIZATIONS YOU
REPRESENT ARE DOING THEIR VERY
BEST.
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
FLOOR.
AND IN TALKING WITH THE OUTSIDE
THE CONCERNED PARTIES THE WATER
DISTRICTS [inaudible]
ARE.
THEY HAVE SPECIFIC CONCERNS NOW
BUT IF THIS TO EIGHTEEN ISSUE.
I DON'T KNOW THE TO EIGHTEEN
DEMANDS THAT [inaudible]
EVERY LITTLE [inaudible]
TRANSACTION.
BE ARE ACCOUNTED FOR AND I CAN'T
IMAGINE THAT THE RECONNECTION
FEE.
WHO AVERAGED OVER TIME WOULD BE
MUCH MORE THAN FIFTY DOLLARS --
YOU MAY HAVE SOME CASES WHERE A
TYRANT SOMEWHERE IT'S LOWER BUT
IF YOU WANT TO COME UP WITH A
DEFINITION --
OR OR TO WORK THAT OUT WITH THE
AUTHOR THAT'S FINE BUT I DON'T
KNOW THAT TO EIGHTEEN REPLY IS A
IS A FACTOR FOR EVERY LITTLE
CHARGE --
HOWEVER I DO THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT WORK OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR DECIDES IT IS THEN YOU
KNOW THAT BELL MAY NOT GO WHERE
WE WANTED TO GO.
A SECOND ISSUE THAT I KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE BUT THOUGH IT DIDN'T
COME UP IN TESTIMONY WAS JUST
WHO CAN SAY THAT A PERSON HAS A
MEDICAL PROBLEM.
ARE WE CLEARLY DON'T WANT THAT
JUST TO BE M. DIS ARE BUT THEY
LIKE A A CLOSER --
DEFINITION.
OF WHO MIGHT BE A MEDICAL.
PERSON TO PITCH YOU COULD DATA
SPEAK FOR THAT.
OUR DEFINITION OF RESIDENTIAL
SERVICE.
UPDATE KNOWLEDGE THE PROBLEM
WITH A MOBILE HOMEOWNER OR
RENTER WHOSE PAIN FOR THE WIDER
BUT THE OWNER IS NOT --
AND THEY WANTED TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT DEFINITION --
AND THEN THERE'S THE QUESTION OF
IF IT'S A P. YOU SEE REGULATED
UTILITY SHOULD THE P. YOU SEE TO
THE ENFORCEMENT RATHER THAN.
THE ETERNAL ATTORNEY GENERAL --
I THINK THOSE ARE THINGS WORTH
YOUR WORTH THINKING ABOUT IF YOU
CAN BRING OFF OPPOSITION.
WHICH I HOPE YOU CAN I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO HAVE THIS.
AS A AS A FLOOR.
AND AGAIN IN THE BILL IT DOES
SPECIFICALLY SAY IF YOU HAVE
OTHER.
WAYS OF REACHING THESE GOALS
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR WHERE WORK LOOKING FOR
REACHING THE GOALS.
SO I WOULD AND AGAIN IF THE HG
IS SAM [inaudible]
ENFORCING THIS --
OR THE P. YOU SEE THEIR NECK AND
LOOK AT EVERY LITTLE THING
THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO KNOW ARE
YOU.
ARE YOU REALLY --
CHIEF IN THE GOAL OF MAKING SURE
PEOPLE'S WIDER IS NOT CUT OFF IN
HIM.
IF THEY'RE HAVING AN EMERGENCY
AND ALSO THAT --
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF A
LIFELINE PROGRAM THAT BECAUSE OF
TO EIGHTEEN WE DON'T HAVE
LIFELINE PROGRAMS THAT'S PRETTY
CLEAR TO EIGHTEEN PROHIBITS
THAT.
AND SO WE HAVE A BIGGER PROBLEM
WITH WATER --
THAN WE DO WITH --
ELECTRICAL WHICH IS MOSTLY DONE
BY THE THREE MAJOR UTILITIES --
ALTHOUGH THAT'S CHANGING TO AN I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO EIGHTEEN WILL
COME INTO WHETHER WILL STILL
HAVE LIFELINE NOW THAT WE HAVE.
A COMMUNITY --
CHOICE AGGREGATION PROGRAMS BUT
WE'LL SEE.
ANYWAY I DO THINK THE BILL IS
NECESSARY AND I'M AT I AM
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE.
AND HOPE THAT THE AUTHOR AND THE
UTILITY WIDER UTILITIES CAN
REACH AN AGREEMENT AS WE GO
FORWARD [inaudible]
ALRIGHT [inaudible]
ALRIGHT --
MISTER MURATSUCHI WOULD YOU LIKE
TO MOVE THE BELL SOME OF SECOND
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY CLOSE THE
CURTAIN CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SB NINE NINE EIGHT DIED
THE MOTION IS DUE PASS AND REAR
FOR TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE.
QUIRK AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS IS NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
LACKEY.
LACKEY IS NO [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
MORE AT SEARCHING.
WHAT'S WHICH IS OUR WELL HOLD IT
OPEN.
ALRIGHT JUST SHARE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR PORTANTINO
[inaudible]
TWELVE SIX ALRIGHT.
SENATOR WELL --
TENURE PORTANTINO WELL --
PRESENT ON SPEAK.
TWELVE SIXTY THREE I'M LOOKING
AT THE WRONG THING.
MOTION TO MOVE ALL OF SIXTY
THREE TO VOTE.
FIND TWELVE SIXTY THREE IT'S
MOVED AND SECONDED AND YOU DO
HAVE ONE ON CONSENT SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S ALRIGHT
THAT'S WHAT I ROTTING AND IN THE
SPIRIT OF THE CAN.
SUPPORT OF SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES
OF A VERY SHORT --
LIKE THAT BEGIN BY THANKING YOUR
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY STAFF
ON AMENDMENTS --
AND I DO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUR FOR TWELVE SIXTY
THREE WHICH REQUIRES THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL. TO ADOPT AND
IMPLEMENT A STATEWIDE MICRO
PLASTIC STRATEGY AND SUBMIT THAT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON A BEFORE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE EXPECT
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND IF
FOLKS TO SUPPORT.
PARENT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS DESK ABOUT GRAHAM AFTER
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES WHERE THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN WHATEVER
YOUR SUPPORT THINKING.
CHAIR MEMBERS MELISSA ROMERO
WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WE'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AGAIN
FOR THOSE CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS.
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THE URGENT
ACTION IS NEEDED TO ADDRESS
PLASTIC POLLUTION AND THAT THIS
BILL IS NOT INTENDED TO PRECLUDE
OTHER STATUTORY CHANGES.
ON THANKS A SENATOR FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON PLASTIC PUSH
REDUCTION THIS YEAR AND ONE TO
SAY THANK YOU TO AMY FROM THE
COMMITTEE FOR HER WORK ON THE
BILL.
AT OR YOUR SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SHARING GREEN CAN --
SYNDICATION DISTRICTS OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU --
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAY SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND THE NINE OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT WITH THESE
AMENDMENTS TO SHORTEN THE
TIMELINE.
AND CLARIFY LANGUAGE THAT THIS
DOESN'T PRECLUDE THE LEGISLATURE
FROM TAKING ACTION WHILE THE
STRATEGY IS BEING DEVELOPED
THANK YOU.
GOING UP WHAT'S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURA WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
VERY GOOD ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SO AYE I THINK THAT THIS IS OUR
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE BILLS LIKE
THIS THAT GIVE US THE DATA WE
NEED. TO KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEMS
ARE AND THEREFORE I HOW WE MIGHT
SOUND THE BEST THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK YOU
FOR TAKING OUR AMENDMENTS AND
RECOMMENDING AND I'VE VOTE.
AND WE WE'VE GOTTEN THERE AND
THE MOTION AND A SECOND SO MADAM
SECRETARY CLOSE THE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS S. B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE
PORTANTINO.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
S. B..
SB TWELVE SIXTY THREE DO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE FOR FOR TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS I KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
WHAT A TO G. I READ CITY I?
THAT WE PASSED.
ALRIGHT SHOW.
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO WE'LL GO TO
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE.
LIKE PRESENT FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
WHICH REQUIRES THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES.
CONTROL BOARD TO ADOPT
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE TESTING OF
MICRO PLASTICS AND DRINKING
WATER.
CURRENTLY WATER TREATMENT
EFFORTS DO NOT ACCOUNT FOR ALL
MICHAEL PLASTICS WHICH IS HOW
FIBERS AND UP AND DRINKING
WATER.
FURTHER RESEARCH IS NECESSARY TO
COOPERATE THE RESULTS OF THE
STUDY AND TO DETERMINE HOW
EXACTLY THE FIBERS IMPACT OUR
HEALTH.
OF THE FACT REMAINS THAT
PLASTICS ARE PRESENT AND WE NEED
TO FIND OUT TO WHAT EXTENT IT'S
CRUCIAL THAT THE PUBLIC BE MADE
AWARE.
OF TO THE EXTENT OF
MICROPROCESSORS PRESENT TO IN
DRINKING WATER AND POTENTIAL --
DANGER THEY POSE TO OUR HEALTH
SO WE NEED MORE INFORMATION IN
THIS GET TO FOR US RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I WROTE.
VERY GOOD.
ARMED IN SUPPORT.
CHAIRED MEMBERS AGAIN MELISSA
ROMERO WITH THE ENVIRONMENT A
GROUP CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO THE PUBLIC
HAS A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT'S IN
THEIR WATER AND SPECIFICALLY
PLASTIC MICROFIBER IS HAVE
EMERGED AS A UNIQUE AND
WIDESPREAD TYPE OF PLASTIC
POLLUTION.
AND AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
RECENT RESEARCH ON THE PRESENCE
OF MEGA PLASTICS AND TAP WATER
AS WELL AS BOTTLED WATER HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT NEEDS TO BE MONITORED
PUBLICLY DISCLOSED AND
ADDRESSED.
AND WE APPRECIATE SANDERS
LEADERSHIP UP ON THIS ISSUE
THANKS.
ALRIGHT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABBOTT ON BEHALF OF
THE ELEVEN MEMBERS OF THE CLEAN
SEIZE LOPPING COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURA AND CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT. THREE
SUBURBAN RICH ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY AND SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT.
DOT OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO TESTIFY.
YOU CAN STAY I BELIEVE.
THERE'S A LITTLE.
WHAT WILL HAVE ENOUGH CHAIRS?
THERE KNOW CLASS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN OPPOSING LESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SP.
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO WE BELIEVE
THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE BILL ARE
PREMATURE FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS INCLUDING A LACK OF
STANDARDIZED DETECTION METHOD
AND RESEARCH RELATED TO THE
HUMAN HEALTH IMPACTS OF MICRO
PLASTICS.
THAT BEING SAID WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
KNOWING MORE ABOUT WHAT'S IN OUR
DRINKING WATER WE PROVIDED
AMENDMENTS TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
BUT ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
APPROACH.
IT'S OUTLINED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS REGARDING UNREGULATED
CONTAMINATE MONITORING RULE FOR
MY PREPOSTEROUS.
COULD BE A PRODUCTIVE PATH
FORWARD AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR IN HIS
OFFICE ON THAT POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
IF YOUR THINK YOU CINDY TECH
WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES AQUA
ALSO HAS AN OPPOSING WITH
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL.
WE HAD SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD FILL SOME OF THE
INFORMATION GAPS SORT OF LIKE
THE PRO CHOICE THAT YOU HAD ON
YOUR OTHER BILL ON OCEAN
PROTECTION SP.
TWELVE SIXTY THREE ARE WE TO
LIKE THE SUGGESTION FROM THIS
COMMITTEE STAFF ABOUT A
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAT'S BASED
ON THE ON ROAD REGULATED
CONTAMINANT MONITORING ROLE.
UP AND WE'D LIKE TO REVIEW IF
THE COMMITTEE COULD GO IN THAT
DIRECTION WE'D LIKE TO REVIEW
THE LANGUAGE BUT WE THINK THAT
COULD WORK WE DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE A PERMANENT RULE GOING
INTO PERPETUITY --
BUT IT WOULD ON HAVE THAT GOV
MONITORING THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
LOOKING.
FOR AND WE ALSO THINK THERE
SHOULD BE A CERTIFIED LAB FOR
THAT.
SO THAT'S OUR COMMENTS WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
CONSIDERATION OF A DIFFERENT
APPROACH.
ALL RIGHT ARM QUESTIONS FROM.
OKAY SHE'S ME OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
A JACK HAWKS CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATION WILL --
WE ALSO ADOPTED POSE UNLESS
AMENDED AND CONCUR WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY OUR QUINCY
ANYWAY [inaudible]
ALRIGHT ARM [inaudible]
QUESTIONS FROM.
MEMBERS OF THE BILL UP OKAY
SECOND.
GO AHEAD.
MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
THEY I I'VE JUST GOT THE FEW
CONCERNS WITH IT AND I LIKE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH IT AND I
KNOW WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THE A HIT
WITH THESE MICRO PLASTICS --
THE I KNOW WHEN WE'RE DONE WITH
AIR QUALITY WE TALK ABOUT PM TWO
POINT FIVE AT THE PARTS PER
MILLION BUT I'M NOT SEEING
ANYTHING DISCUSSING WHAT THE
PART FOR MILLIONS GONNA BE.
WHAT THAT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE WHAT
THE ACTUAL HUMAN A FAX GONNA BE?
AND THEN AT WHAT WALT IMPORTANT.
TWO NOTIFIER FOLKS BACK HOME YOU
KNOW HEY THIS IS HAPPENING THIS
IS IN YOUR WATER.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT DOES AFFECTS
ARE GOING TO BE ON HUMANS
[inaudible]
ARE.
IT AND I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME OF
THAT REFLECTED IN THE LANGUAGE
JUST SO SO WAS WERE LETTING
PEOPLE KNOW HEY THIS IS IN OUR
WATER.
WHAT IS THAT ME?
THE BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO SEE
--
A PANDEMIC ON WHERE HE FREAKS
OUT.
BECAUSE THIS IS IN THEIR WATER
AND THEY ALL RUNNING GO BUY
BOTTLED WATER WHICH AS WE KNOW
BOTTLED WATER STANDARDS ARE.
RIDLEY LOWER THAN WHAT OUR TAP
WATER STANDARDS ARE.
ON THE AND I'VE BEEN A PLENTY OF
PLANTS IN IN WHEN YOU LOOKAT
MICROPORTABLE OLOGY AND
EVERYTHING ELSE GOING ON A IT'S
JUST I'M I'M TRYING TO FATHOM
WHAT.
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO GET THROUGH
ONE OF THOSE SYSTEMS.
AND IF IT IS SOMETHING THAT GETS
THROUGH THE SYSTEMS IT'S GONNA
BE SO SMALL IT'S GONNA GO
DIRECTLY INTO YOUR BLOODSTREAM
ANYWAY --
WHICH BRINGS OTHER TERRIFYING
PAID IS IN A PLACE.
SO I MEAN I JUST LIKE TO SEE
SOMETHING.
WITHIN THE LANGUAGE THEY
IDENTIFY SOME OF THOSE SO THAT
WAY.
IT AS THESE THINGS ARE DETECTED
WE'RE NOT JUST ON PEOPLE HEY
THERE'S MICHAEL PLASTICS INNER
WATER --
BECAUSE I CAN LEAD TO OTHER
THINGS NOW I THINK IT'S HAVE
POINT WELL TAKEN AND WITH THE
AGENCIES AS WELL.
YOU KNOW IT'S OUR HOPE AS THIS
PROGRESSES TO WORK WITH.
THE STAKEHOLDERS AS WE'VE BEEN
DOING THROUGH THE WHOLE PROCESS.
NOT BECAUSE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF INFORMATION TO KNOW
WHAT I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT.
AND ONCE WE KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT IS IT MEAN AND WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO WITH THAT INFORMATION.
AND THOSE ARE PART OF THE
ONGOING DISCUSSIONS SO --
I THINK THERE'S ROOM TO PUT
THOSE PROVISIONS IN THE I I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH.
BUT WE JUST HAVEN'T WORDSMITH
THEM YET BUT YOU KNOW WILL WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND WILL WORK
WITH THE NOT SO SUBTLE BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL AND THEY I
JUST A AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT I GET TO ADDRESS
NOT I GREW.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
ARM ACQUIESCED AND I WILL OKAY.
THEN IF THEY'RE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS --
SO I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL AND WE'RE GONNA FIND WHEN
THERE IS TESTING I HOPE THERE IS
THE HOPE THE BILL GETS FORWARD.
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR.
BOB THAT SOME IS WILL HAVE A LOT
OF MICRO PLASTICS AND SOME WILL
HAVE VERY LITTLE I SUSPECT WHERE
I LIVED IN HAYWARD WHERE THE
WATER COMES FROM.
GREAT FOR COMES OFF THE GRANITE
NEO SAMITY THAT --
THERE'S NO MICHAEL PLASTICS TO
SPEAK UP.
WHERE I LIVE NOW IN UNION CITY?
SPECTER COULD BE QUITE A BIT
BECAUSE WE GET WATER FROM OUT OF
THE DELTA --
WHERE IT'S?
WELL ALSO OF THINGS AND THAT
WERE DRINKING THE SEWAGE FROM
SACRAMENTO AMONG OTHER PLACES --
AT ANY RATE I'M I ALSO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION
TO SEE IF YOU CAN I BRING
OPPOSITION OFF IT WILL CERTAINLY
HELP.
I GET THE BILL FORWARD AND IT'S
ALWAYS HARD --
WHEN THERE'S OPPOSITION TO BE
SURE THE BILL WILL PASS AND WELL
LIME?
A B. SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR SO
IF SOMETHING CAN BE DONE THERE
THAT'S CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
VERY HELPFUL SAU.
RECOMMENDING AYE VOTE --
POINT ONE OF THE POINTS MADE WAS
THAT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
PHYSICAL EFFECTS ARE YET.
I THINK MAYBE THAT'S A TOPIC FOR
ANOTHER BILL.
BUT WITHOUT --
KNOWING WHERE THE PLASTIC
PROBLEM IS --
WHEN WE DO GET THE INFORMATION
WE WON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
IT'S I THINK?
IT'S TWO SIDES OF A COIN YOU'VE
DONE ONE SIDE PERHAPS NEXT YEAR
WE CAN DO THE OTHER SIDE.
THAT BEING SAID --
WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND I'M
RECOMMENDING IT AYE VOTE AND
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
PORTANTINO DO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MATHIS
[inaudible]
MATHIS I KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I HOLDEN.
WHAT A TO G.?
MINUTES WHICH I SWEAR FOR VOTES
THEIR CURRENT NEW APPAREL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
WELL WHOEVER.
BAGHDAD'S OKAY THE SENATE.
YEAH OKAY WE HAD MADRE SO.
THIS IS A GOOD MEASURE TO BE
BRIEFED ON THANK YOU.
I HOPE THEY'RE ALL GOOD THINGS
[inaudible]
CHAU.
WE ARE GOING TO HEAR S. J. OUR
TWENTY TWO FROM SENATOR WEST.
THANK YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE ALL
YOUR HELP WITH THIS MEASURE.
OUR SCR TWENTY TWO IS WAY LONG
OVERDUE.
IT'S RESOLUTION WHICH URGES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE US IV
WC TO TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
ADEQUATELY ADDRESS.
CROSS BORDER POLLUTION AND
REQUIRE VALLEY OF COURSE I BE W.
C. AS OUR ADVOCATE.
IN NEGOTIATING TREATIES WITH
MEXICO.
BOB.
THE DECLINE RIVER VALLEY AS ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT.
ECOLOGY'S A IN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND OF COURSE IT'S ALSO ONE OF
THE OF MOST THREATENED.
AT THE RIVERS IN AND OUT
CALIFORNIA YEAH THE SEWAGE THAT
--
POURS INTO THAT IS PRETTY MUCH
KILLING THE ENVIRONMENT THERE
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ESTUARY.
IT'S AND RAMS OUR SIDE
ESTABLISHED BY THE U..
U. N. RAMS ARE COMMITTEE THERE
ONLY A FEW ROUNDS ARE SITES IN
THE WORLD.
THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
AND WITH TO REM'S OUR SON RAMS
OUR SITE IS --
AN ENVIRONMENTAL SITE OF OF
ECOLOGICAL IMPORTANCE TO THE
WORLD IT'S A VERY UNIQUE SITE
AND THERE AREN'T VERY MANY OF
THEM IN THE WORLD AND THOSE ARE
--
SITES THAT ARE THREATENED.
THAT NEED TO BE PROTECTED AND
THEY NEED TO BE RESTORED.
AND THAT HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH. TO
MOTIVATE THE AYE BWC TO ACT AND
AND TAKE ACTIONS TO THE
APPROPRIATE ACTIONS. TO REDUCE
THOSE.
OUR WASTE WATER [inaudible]
OF FLOWS.
I FROM MEXICO.
THAT HAVE CREATED --
JUSTA A BIG BIG PROBLEM THERE --
WE HAVE HAD. TWENTY EIGHT RAW
SEWAGE SPILLS.
TOTALING APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
MILLION GALLONS OF RAW SEWAGE.
BETWEEN TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ALONE.
ARE THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO HAS
HAD.
STATE OF EMERGENCY FOR THE TO
QUITE A RIVER VALLEY AT LEAST
FOR THE LAST. TWENTY FOUR YEARS
THAT I KNOW.
NOTHING HAS BEEN DONE.
AND I I APPLAUD.
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HOWEVER SEVEN OFF FOR INITIATING
LAWSUIT AGAINST UAB WC.
YOU KNOW IT IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHO'S BEEN YOU KNOW THE
PRESIDENT OF THE COUNTRY A
DOESN'T MATTER IT'S JUST THAT
HAS NOT WORKED.
THIS HAS NOT BEEN MATE AND A UP
PRIOR BUT IT BY ANY
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THIS IS CREATING A A
REDUCTION IN PROPERTY VALUES AND
IMPERIAL BEACH AND IN SAN DIEGO.
IT'S BECAUSE JUST A HEALTH
CONCERNS OF THE SPREAD OF OF
VIRUSES THROUGH MOSQUITOES ME
WE'VE.
IT'S A DISASTER.
AND AND AND TIMES UP I THINK THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS HAD
PLENTY OF TIME TO JUST ENFORCE
THE TREATIES THAT WE HAVE WE
HAVE TREATIES.
THAT GET TO THIS ISSUE.
AND THERE IS JUST NO ENFORCEMENT
NO INTEREST TO MAKE.
IMPROVEMENTS THERE AND ALL THE
DECISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
HAVE ONLY MADE THINGS WORSE.
AND WE'RE ASKING THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DO ITS JOB
AND STEP UP AND BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THE STATE IS
LIMITED AS TO WEEK WHAT WE CAN
DO BECAUSE OF THE BORDER READ
REGION.
YOU KNOW I'VE EVEN TRIED TO
CREATE -- US
BUT THIS SPECIAL PLANNING OVERS
ON THAT CREATES A A WATERSHED
MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR THE QUAN
ARRIVE ALLEY.
AND OF COURSE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAS JURISDICTION SO THAT CAN
HAPPEN AND WE'VE I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS. FOR FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS SO EASILY --
AND AND IT'S GETTING FRUSTRATING
BECAUSE I JUST DON'T FEEL LIKE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS OUR
PARTNER.
IN MANY INSTANCES OF THE MEXICAN
SIDE OF THE BORDER HAS BEEN A
LITTLE MORE ACCOMMODATING THAT
ARE ON FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IT'S
JUST IT'S JUST A MASSIVE
BUREAUCRACY AND I THINK THE ONLY
THING THAT WE NEED TO RESOLVE
THIS IS IS A JUDICIAL DECISION.
AND I THINK IF WE PUT DISTANCE
THROUGH THE COURTS THAT WOULD
REALLY HELP.
BUT THIS THIS RESOLUTION I THINK
IS NEEDED TO HELP WITH THIS
LAWSUIT. TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WE HAVE THE WEIGHT OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE MAKING
THIS PRIORITY FOR OUR STATE.
NOW APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE HERE
TODAY THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
MATTER.
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE MADE A VERY ELEGANT STATEMENT
THANK YOU --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YEAH ALRIGHT.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND THE SECOND
ARM YOU HAVE SPOKE AND WE DO WE
ARE LACKEY INC MATHIS MADE A
MOTION.
THANK OKAY HER ARM.
SO.
I THIS IS CLEARLY.
ARM THAT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
PROBLEM PROBLEM WHICH REGARDLESS
WHO HAS BEEN PRESIDENT TOUR.
IN CONGRESS IS NOT BEEN SOLVED
--
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND A MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS THIS IS SJR TWENTY TWO
WESO.
THE MOTION IS TO BE ADOPTED
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I HOLDEN.
WHAT IT WHICH I REJECT?
OKAY WARS ELIZALDE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH
.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE SENATOR
HERTZBERG.
MOVE THE BILL.
ALRIGHT WE'RE HEARING --
S. B..
TWELVE FIFTEEN THANK YOU SIR I
HAD THANK YOU THINK CHAU MAKE IT
QUICK.
ARMED AYE DISTRICT FOR THE
RECORD I AGREED TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED IN THIS
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
ARM [inaudible]
AND THESE WERE THE FRAMEWORK OF
THIS BILL.
IS THAT IT DURING THE DROUGHT
MANY LOW INCOME COMMITTEES
ACROSS THE STATE.
RELIED ON FAILED WATER SYSTEMS
THAT PROVIDE UNSAFE AND BUT
LIABLE DRINKING WATER SO THROUGH
A SERIES OF IT ISSUES THE THE
STATE INITIALLY IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WITH S. B. FIVE FIVE TWO
BY SENATOR WALK.
AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY IN THE
BUDGET BILL S. B. EIGHTY EIGHT
WITH MISTER LENO.
ALLOW THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO LOOKED
CONSOLIDATIONS OF THE SMALLER
DISTRICTS IN AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
ON THE WATER SUPPLY SIDE TO HELP
FOLKS.
NOW WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
YOU CAN HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES
IS TO EXTEND THAT SAME
PHILOSOPHY.
TO OF FOR FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO ALLOW THAT THE
BOARD TO EXTEND THIS WITH
RESPECT TO WASTE WATER SERVICES
SIMILAR KINDS OF CHALLENGES
ALTERNATE OVER THE WITNESSES.
WILL ANSWER THE QUESTIONS BUT WE
HAVE RICHARD TRANSLATE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I LOVE WHEN I SEVENTH ME NUMBERS
LIKE MINDED YOU'LL BE ONE AND
CLEANED ALL THE FACE NO.
MIKO MONEY THAT IS CHEN GUNS A
STABLE SINGLE CLASS OF THE LAST
TWO THAT THE PHRASE NO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MONDAY
AGO SOMEONE I LIVE IN FRESNO
COUNTY COMMUNITY OF JANE ADAMS
JUST FIVE HOUSES FROM THE CITY
OF FRESNO.
BANGLA THANK AYE SAID BECAUSE
EBOOK ONE LEVEL UNDER
CANONICAL'S FEE OF THE QUE LA
WAKSAL'S HE ADVOCATE IF ELECT
CASA.
OAKLAND THUMBING ITS WAY --
TO AYE RELY ON A SEPTIC TANK AND
I LIVE WITH THE THE ANGUISHED
ANXIETY THAT DIRTY WATER WILL
RETURN TO MY HOME OR CONTAMINATE
THE SOIL AROUND MY HOUSE.
GET AGREEMENT THAT MET LAST TO
THAT FATAL MOST BORN AND NOT
THE%
SCHOOL IDOL SCHOOLS BOTH YOU'RE
STUCK Y. LAS MILLIONTH.
I'D LIKE TO CONNECT TO THE CITY
BUT THEY PUT VERY HIGH COSTS AND
OBSTACLES IN OUR WAY.
BUT FROM WHAT UP AGAIN EXCEPT
REPLACE THAT BUT US THAT WOULD.
GET THOUGHT MICHAEL MONEY THAT.
IS THE FEDERAL OF AND PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL TO MAKE
SURE THAT MY COMMUNITY AND
OTHERS LIKE IT ARE HEALTHY
[inaudible]
IT'S VERY --
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MIKE
CLAIBORNE I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
AND THE AUTHOR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
SB -- TWELVE
FIFTEEN MARIA'S EXPERIENCE IS
REALLY EMBLEMATIC OF THE WASTE
WATER PROBLEMS IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND EAST
COACHELLA VALLEY AND REALLY THE
STATE --
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF SITES AT
NEIGHBORHOODS AND SYSTEMS IN THE
STATE THAT RELY ON FAILING
SEPTIC SYSTEMS.
THIS IS BOTH A THREAT TO WATER
QUALITY --
NITRATES GETTING THE GROUND
WATER -- AND
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE AND THEN
THE BACTERIA THAT GETS IN THE
SOIL FROM FAILING UMP SEPTIC
TANKS -- SO.
WE RECENTLY TOOK TO THE TWO
SEPARATE SOIL SAMPLES AND THE
COMMUNITY OF DEL AYE.
AYE NEAR SEPTIC TANKS AND THEY
ACTUALLY THE YARDS LOOKED OKAY
AND EVERYTHING --
BUT THOSE SOIL SAMPLES CAME BACK
POSITIVE --
FOR SEVERAL TYPES OF BACTERIA
AND INCLUDING LISTERIA --
COLI REALLY DANGEROUS
BACTERIA THESE ARE SEPTIC TANKS
RIGHT BY THE FRONT DOORS OF
PEOPLE'S HOUSES --
AND THEIR KIDS PLAYING IN ONE OF
THE YARDS RIGHT WHEN WE TOOK THE
SOIL SAMPLES --
SO THERE'S REALLY IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH HAZARD AND AT A DANGEROUS
SITUATION THAT WE SHOULD REALLY
WRITE RESOLVE.
THEIR BARRIERS IN PLACE THAT
MAKE --
EXTENSIONS OF SERVICE IN THIS
AREA MORE DIFFICULT --
THERE'S OFTENTIMES FUNDING FOR
THESE PROJECTS --
THAT MY ORGANIZATION WORKS ON
BUT THEY'RE OFTEN POLITICAL
BARRIERS TO GETTING THE PROJECTS
DONE -- IF
YOU LOOK AND WALK THROUGH OUR
DRIVE THROUGH DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
YOU'LL OFTEN SEE PATCHES OF
GREEN GRASS AND A DRY YARD
THAT'S KIND OF A SQUARE SHAPE.
OFTEN THAT MEANS THAT THE SEPTIC
TANK IN THAT YARD IS FAILING IF
YOU DRIVE THROUGH THE IT'S NOT
--
COMMUNITIES THAT'S ACTUALLY
PRETTY COMMON EXPERIENCE --
SO THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT WE
NEED TO SOLVE THIS BILL I THINK
IS THE WAY TO DO IT SO I'D ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANKS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FROM OTHER WITNESSES IN SPORT
ALOE WE HAVE A GREAT WITNESS
COMING OUT.
THERE IS A MICROPHONE THERE
THAT'LL YEAH THAT'S IT.
WAYNE HI MY NAME IS DIANA AND I
LIVE IN FRESNO AND I GO TO
BORDER TOWN.
PLEASE SUPPORT DISPEL SO WE CAN
HAVE A HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOOD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANY METALLICS LEON WE HAVE THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
HI JUSTIN MASSEY WITH COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND SUPPORT.
ANDREA VENTURE WITH CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD --
LET'S SEE.
DID THAT I CHAINED AS FOR
OPPOSITION BUT FOR ANYONE WANTS
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
TRAINER --
YOU'RE YOU'RE WELCOME. TO TO
STATE YOUR CONCERN WHY DON'T YOU
--
IF YOU WANT TO SIT DOWN YOU CAN
SIT DOWN IF YOU WANT TO STAND
YOU COULD STAND [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND WILL CERTAINLY BE GLAD TO
LISTEN TO WHATEVER YOUR CONCERTS
ARE --
MARIANNE WARMER DOWN DRUG COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES THE ALIFORNIA
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS.
AND OUT WE JUST WERE I WANT TO
BE HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE MECHANICS OF
THE BILL.
A ONE ALSO START OUT BY SAYING
WE REALLY APPRECIATES A CENTER
HERTZBERG BRING THIS FORWARD.
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY THE MIRROR
IMAGE OF A COUPLE OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
HAVING TO DO WITH SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
ON THAT SENATOR MONNING HAS PUT
FORWARD AND WE BELIEVE THIS --
THAT THE PROVISION OF WATER
TREATMENT AT THAT BACKEND AS IT
WERE.
HAS SOME OF THE SAME CHALLENGES.
NAMELY OF FINDING THE FUNDING
THE ABILITY OF THE COMMUNITY TO
SUPPORT THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
IS MADE AVAILABLE.
AND THE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND EXISTING SYSTEMS AND
EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTE THE COST OF
THAT.
NEW [inaudible]
CAPACITY SO WE BELIEVE THAT WHAT
SENATOR HERTZBERG IST IS TRYING
TO GET TO IS UNNECESSARY.
ASPECT OF PROVIDING A COMPLETE
AND SAFE WATER DRINKING SYSTEM.
PARTICULARLY FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES MANY OF THEM ARE IN
OUR COUNTIES SOARED BARELY
KEENLY AWARE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS.
BUT WE DO HAVE SOME RESERVATIONS
ABOUT THE CURRENT APPROACH AND I
WOULD CONCUR WITH SOME OF THE
ITEMS RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
WE'D BE VERY HAPPY.
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT MIGHT
GET TO SOME OF THE MECHANICS OF
PROVIDING THEM FUNDING TO MAKE
THESE.
NEW SYSTEMS COME ALIVE FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS JUST
CUT GALLAGHER AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION AGENCIES I WOULD LIKE
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUE A OF AGREE WITH
SEVERAL OF THE ISSUES THAT SHE
I'M BROUGHT FORWARD.
I AM HERE TODAY NOT IN
OPPOSITION BUT TO JUST
RESPECTFULLY EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
AMENDED --
ON FRIDAY SO WE'RE STILL SORTING
THROUGH A SORT OF HOW THOSE.
AMENDMENTS ARE GOING TO IMPACT
WASTE WATER AGENCIES BUT THERE
ARE A FEW SPECIFIC COMPONENT
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY AND
DIFFICULT FOR US AND THESE
INCLUDE THE NEW LANGUAGE --
THAT ALLOWS THE REGIONAL BOARD
TO ORDER AN EXTENSION OF SERVICE
WITH ACCESS CAPACITY AND THEN.
GIVE THE STATE BOARD THE RIGHTS
TO THAT ACCESS CAPACITY FOR FIVE
YEARS AND THAT'S AT WITHOUT
PAYING THE CONNECTION FEES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ADDITIONAL
CAPACITY --
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT A
LOCAL AGENCIES DUE PROCESS
RIGHTS WITH --
THE NEW AMENDMENTS AND DON'T
NEED TO GET INTO THE DETAILS
THERE BUT I WOULD LIKE TO KIND
OF WERE WHAT WORK.
FISCAL SENSE --
ME NOTE THAT AND THE POLICY
HAMBURG OUTLINED IN THE BILL
SHOULD BE CLARIFIED AS TO
WHETHER IT'S A BINDING
REGULATORY DOCUMENT OR IF IT'S
MORE OF A FLEXIBLE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENT AND THEN --
WE JUST HAVE SOME PRACTICAL
CONCERNS.
WITH HOW THIS PROCESS WOULD WORK
KIND OF ON THE GROUND --
IT'S UNCLEAR WHO WOULD DETERMINE
THE COST OF INTERCONNECTION
WHETHER THAT.
YOU NOW --
OTHER THINGS LIKE WHETHER THE
FEES ARE REASONABLE.
WHAT FORM THE REASON REGIONAL
BOARDS ORDER WOULD TAKE --
SO YOU KNOW IS THIS IN FORSMAN
ORDER AGAINST A LOCAL AGENCY WE
DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
APPROPRIATE --
SINCE WE HAVEN'T HAD A WATER
QUALITY VIOLATION IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE I IT'S ALSO UNCLEAR
HOW THESE ACTIONS WOULD WORK
WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
MULTIPLE LOCAL AGENCIES SO.
IN SOME CASES THE NEAREST
ADJACENT LOCAL SYSTEM WOULD BE
LIKE A CITY.
ARE OWNED AND OPERATED
COLLECTIONS SYSTEM BUT THEN AND
THERE WOULD BE AN A LARGER
REGIONAL ENTITY WHO WOULD NEED
TO IT AND MAKE DETERMINATIONS
ABOUT.
DOWNSTREAM IMPACTS TREATMENT
CAPACITY AND AND THAT CONNECTION
FEES AND THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
SO ON YOU KNOW DOES THE ORDER
APPLY TO BOTH ENTITIES ITS KIND
OF UNCLEAR IN THE LANGUAGE
CURRENTLY SO.
AND SOME OVERARCHING ISSUES
THAT.
ABOUT WE'D ALSO LIKE TO SEE
STRONGER LANGUAGE ON THE SERVICE
EXTENSIONS BEING COMPLAIN WITH
PROP.
TWO EIGHTEEN AND THE ADEQUATE
FINANCING BE SECURED PRIOR TO
ANY EXTENSIONS BEING ORDERED AND
THEN -- FOR
THE CLARITY ON THE TYPES OF
COMMUNITIES THAT THE BILL'S
TARGETING SO.
I DO JUST WANNA KNOW.
SOMEONE RC RC THAT --
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT OBJECTING IN
ANY WAY TO FINDING SOLUTION UP
THE FINDING A SOLUTION FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES WITH FEELING SEPTIC
SYSTEMS WE CERTAINLY EMPATHIZE
SYMPATHIZE WITH THESE SITUATIONS
--
AND OUR MEMBERS EXIST TO PROTECT
WATER QUALITY IN THE PUBLIC
HEALTH SO.
OF WE WE DO WANT TO SEE THIS
PROPOSED PROGRAM REFLECT A
REASONABLE AND WORKABLE OF
PROCESS AND UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY.
DOESN'T QUITE FIT THERE FOR US
SO -- WITH
THAT WE APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF OUR COMMENTS
AND WERE OPENED TO CONTINUING
THIS CONVERSATION WITH UNDER
HERTZBERG GONNA STAFF.
AND YOUR COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
THE SECOND SET.
GOD THAT'S RIGHT I CAN THAT
STORY DONE.
GREAT OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY GOD [inaudible]
A SO WE HAVE.
WHERE ARE WE NOW WE'VE OWE ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION?
I SHOULD PERHAPS SAY YOU WORKED
SO MUCH IN OPPOSITION IS AS
TRYING -- TO
MAKE CONSTRUCTIVE COMMENTS THANK
YOU [inaudible]
ARM.
LET'S SEE ARE QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS.
UP MR MATHIS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SO.
THEY A OF COUNTY COMMENT ON THIS
BECAUSE MY DISTRICT WAS.
THE EPICENTER OF OF THE DROUGHT
AND EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED
AND IS ONE OF THE UNFORTUNATE
EPICENTERS OF A LOT OF VERY BAD
WATER -- TO
I DO APPRECIATE --
THE WITNESS COMING FORWARD I I
KNOW I'VE BEEN ON SEVERAL TOURS
IN THE DISTRICT.
I AM LOOKING AT THIS THAT THIS
IS PART OF WHY WE DID AND MY THE
LAST YEAR --
AB.
TWO SEVEN SEVEN WHICH WAS THE
WATER AND WASTEWATER LOAN AND
GRANT PROGRAM.
DO LOW INTEREST LOANS AND GRANTS
--
FOR TYING IN INCLUDING SEPTIC.
ARMS I BELIEVE THE WAY WE WROTE
THAT LAST YEAR.
WOULD BE ABLE.
TO TIE IN SOME OF THE FUNDING.
FOR TIENEN THE SYSTEMS.
NOT AT LEAST FROM THE RESIDENCE.
INTO THE INFRASTRUCTURE I KNOW
THERE'S GOING TO BE CONCERNS
OBVIOUSLY.
NOW WITH ROLL COUNTERS AND IT
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE ISSUES WE DEALT WITH.
PORTABLE WAS WE HAD COUNTY
PROPERTIES.
THAT HAD TO GET [inaudible]
EXISTING LINES CONNECTED BETWEEN
THE CITY OUT TO COUNTY OF LANDS.
IN AN ANNEX PROCESS --
THE AND I CAN UNDERSTAND SOME
HEARTBURN THEIR ON BEHALF OF OUR
COUNTIES --
ON WHO'S LIABLE IN IN FOR DOING
THESE THINGS FOR THE FACT IS
THEY HAVE TO GET DONE WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A COMPREHENSIVE WAY
OF DOING THAT --
SENATE LOVES TALKING MORE IN IN
THE DAY AGAIN ON HOW.
ON TWO SEVEN SEVEN OF I KNOW THE
GOVERNOR PUT MONEY IN THAT
PROGRAM THIS YEAR WITHIN THE
BUDGET.
HOBBES I KNOW THE MONEY IS THERE
--
THE IN THAT SRT PASSED THROUGH.
STILL I LOVES HOCKEY MORE AND
POSSIBLY TALK AS COMING ON AS A
CO AUTHOR OF WE FEEL IF YOU WANT
BECAUSE WILL LET'S LET'S TALK --
LATER IN IN GO OVER A FEW THINGS
IN AND MAKE SURE OF MY RURAL
COUNTIES ARE PROTECTED AS WELL
--
BUT BUT I DO LIKE WE'RE GOING
THIS IS EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
NEEDED --
BLACK AT ONE OF THE BIGGEST
THINGS THAT'S BOTHERING ME RIGHT
NOW IS I HAVE A LOT OF AG GUYS
THAT ARE GETTING HIT --
FOR ME BEING ACCUSED OF
CONTAMINATION AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF WHAT'S KNOWN AS LEGACY
ISSUES.
ARE DUE TO SEPTIC TANKS --
THAT ARE FLOATING OUT THERE AS
WELL.
SO WHAT I'M HOPING NOW SOME OF
THIS MIGHT HELP RESOLVE SOME OF
THAT AS WELL.
SELECT FLORIDA TALKING WITH YOU
AND SEEING HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS YEAH THANK YOU
INSTANT MATHIS YOU KNOW I I AM
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING IS A
COUPLE SMALL PARTS MIGHT THE
COMMITTEES ARE REPRESENT THAT
THIS INCLUDES BUT IS CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT OVERSEES
WATER I'M.
TRY TO TAKE COMPREHENSIVE VIEW.
FROM STORM WATER TO RECYCLE
WATER TO THE ISSUES WE JUST SAW
THE LEGISLATION WITH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FRIEDMAN THAT WE JUST
PASSED.
DEALING WITH EFFICIENCY AND
TRYING TO KIND OF RE ENGINEER IF
YOU WILL SOME OF THE LARGER
PROBLEMS BEEN.
WITH WITH MR MINING WITH RESPECT
TO HIS ISSUE I KNOW THAT THESE
ARE CHALLENGING BUT BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IS THAT IS THAT
WE'VE GOT TO RE ENGINEER HOW WE
DEAL WITH WATER ON THE ONE HAND
INTO WE'VE GOT THAT FOOD
FUNDAMENTALLY DEAL WITH THE
LARGER ISSUE OF MORE.
WAS A THREE HUNDRED WATER
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
AGAIN AND THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
CHALLENGES WE GOT A YOU KNOW
COME TO IT AND GET IT FIXED IN
YOUR UNFORTUNATELY IN AN AREA
THAT SO DRAMATICALLY IMPACTED
SO.
YOU KNOW OFTEN WE DO MATTERS AND
WILL ONLY WITH THEIR OWN
DISTRICT I WORK ON MATTERS THAT
TRIDENT LOOK AT THE BROADER
PUBLIC POLICY SO I DON'T SHOULD
BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU THAT
ABSOLUTELY AND I ALSO HAVE A A
CA TWENTY EIGHT THAT'S TALKING
ABOUT A FUNDING.
SOLUTIONS WHILE GOING ABOUT THAT
MUCH TIME.
THANK YOU CERTAINLY MEMBER --
OTHERS WITH QUESTIONS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SENATORS
RATIONAL THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY.
SO ARM FIRST OF ALL THANKS TO
ALL THE WITNESSES --
FOR COMING FORWARD AND AND AND
DISCUSSING THEIR CONCERNS
[inaudible]
AND SUPPORT [inaudible]
ARM.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE SENATOR
BRINGING FORWARD A BILL WHICH IS
GOING TO HELP ALL OF US IN ALL
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE ALWAYS VIEWED MY ROLE
HERE IS NOT JUST REPRESENTING MY
DISTRICT BUT FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AND ARM.
I COME FROM A RELATIVELY WELL
OFF THE THEY DON'T THINK FOR
THEMSELVES IS THAT WAY BUT A
RELATIVELY WELL OFF DISTRICT.
AND I REALLY HAVE COMPASSION FOR
THE CONCERNS THAT SHOW UP IN
THESE.
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY ARE IN THIS
JOB.
WE WERE JUST STARTING THAT THE
TIJUANA VALLEY.
ARM THEIR PARTS OF THE STATE
THAT JUST NEED A LOT OF HELP AND
I WANNA MAKE SURE THEY GET IT.
TO THANK YOU FOR AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
BOB MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS SB TWELVE FIFTEEN
HERTZBERG DO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
BUT I WILL [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I HOLDEN.
WHAT A TO G. AYE MORRELL TO GI?
WE HAVE.
FIVE VERY GOOD YOUR HOW YOU
PASSED THE BILL OUT [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
YEAH LAST FILM.
HERE YES.
GENERAL WIENER [inaudible]
OKAY.
SHE READ A STARK ABOUT S. B..
NINE SIXTY SIX YEAH THANK YOU.
AND I AM.
NOT GONNA MAKE IT BAFFLES
[inaudible]
PRODUCT [inaudible]
OF TAKE YOUR TIME.
OF I WILL BE BRIEF BECAUSE THIS
IS THE I THINK IT THE MOM AND
APPLE PIE KIND OF BUILT.
ON COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR
HEARING THIS BILL S. B. NINE
SIXTY SIX OUGHT WILL REQUIRE THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES BOARD.
TO PUT LONG OVERDUE HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS IN PLACE FOR ON
SITE OUR WATER WE USE IN
CALIFORNIA.
ON MANY ARE CITIES WOULD LIKE TO
IMPLEMENT AN ON SITE WATER USE
PROGRAM BUT THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS
ARE -- SO --
THIS WILL ALLOW THE PROCESS TO
MOVE FORWARD WE WORKED
INTENSIVELY.
OUT WITH THAT THE WITH THE
AGENCY -- I
THINK WE HAVE A REALLY STRONG
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I GO OUT WITH ME TODAY TO
COMMENT BRIEFLY.
OR PUBLIC APOLOGY HO UP FROM AND
SEND THE CLERK FROM SUSTAINABLE
SILICON VALLEY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
PAULA KEY HELL I'M WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
OF PUBLIC WATER A UTILITY IN THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
--
AS YOU'RE AWARE MANY UTILITIES
ARE FACING INCREASING CHALLENGES
ON A WATER STRESS AND AND IN
PARTICULAR WATER SUPPLIES AND TO
MEET SOME OF THESE CHALLENGES
UTILITIES ARE WORKING VERY HARD
TO DO IT DIVERSIFY THEIR WATER
SUPPLY PORTFOLIOS.
CONSERVATION AS WE ALL KNOW IS
ONE OF THOSE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX --
IN SAN FRANCISCO IS PROMOTED
CONSERVATION FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS ARE TODAY ARE
RESIDENTIAL PER CAPITA IS FORTY
THREE GALLONS PER PERSON PER DAY
IT'S APPROXIMATELY HALF OF THE
STATE AVERAGE.
A BUT WE ALSO HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY A TO PROMOTE WATER
USE EFFICIENCY ALMOND THAT'S
THEIR ON SITE NON POTABLE WATER
SYSTEMS --
AND THESE ON SITE NON POTABLE
WATER SYSTEMS AND BUILDINGS AND
DISTRICTS IN AND OUR CITIES AND
TOWNS CAN SAVE UP 250% OF
POTABLE WATER --
IN WHAT WE NEED TODAY THOUGH A
RISK BASED WATER QUALITY
STANDARDS THAT ARE PROTECTIVE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH OF WHEN WE
INSTALLED THESE ONSITE WATER
TREATMENT SYSTEMS.
AND SB NINE SIX SIX DOES JUST
THAT IT DIRECTS THE STATE BOARD
TO ESTABLISH A RISK BASED WATER
QUALITY STANDARDS OF MODERATES
MONITORING CRITERIA AND
REPORTING --
NOTIFICATION AND PUBLIC
INFORMATION REQUIREMENTS AS WELL
AS CROSS CONNECTION REQUIREMENTS
--
AND NOT SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT
FLUSHING ARE TOILETS WITH
TOILETS WITH HIGH QUALITY
DRINKING WATER IS PROBABLY NOT
THE BEST USE OF OUR WATER
SUPPLIES --
AND SO WE ASK THAT WE HAVE MORE
TOOLS IN OUR TOOL BOX SUCH AS
INSTALLING ON SITE WATER
TREATMENT SYSTEMS TO TREAT A
WATER FOR NON POTABLE USES SUCH
AS TOILET FLUSHING AN
IRRIGATION.
SO WE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT IN S. B. NINE SIX
SIX THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE.
I AM CINDY CLERK I AND THE
SENIOR WATER DIRECTOR OF
SUSTAINABLE SILICON VALLEY
REVIVAL ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT
THEM IN SANTA CLARA.
OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE SMALL
BUSINESSES LARGE BUSINESSES
CITIES TOWNS THE COUNTY OF A
WATER AGENCIES ALL WORKING
TOGETHER. TO INCREASE OUR
SUSTAINABILITY IN OUR IT IS
ETHICALLY SUPPORT S. B. NINE SIX
SIX FOR OVER THREE YEARS WE'VE
BEEN EDUCATING FOLKS ON IT AND
PROMOTING IT --
TODAY OF ANOTHER TOUCHY ABOUT
THREE THINGS THAT WE'VE
ENCOUNTERED THAT DEMONSTRATE THE
NEED AND IMPORTANCE FOR THE
SPELL.
NUMBER ONE ON ON SITE ON
PORTABLE REDUCE OFFERS A VARIETY
OF BENEFITS.
THE SYSTEMS CONTRIBUTE LOCAL
WATER SUPPLY WHICH IS DROUGHT
RESISTANT.
ADOPTION CAN HELP NORMALIZE ALL
TYPES OF RECYCLING.
AND THE SYSTEMS ARE PAPER WITH
PRIVATE DOLLARS.
SO THE PATHWAY NUMBER TWO THE
PATHWAY FOR BUSINESSES TO
INSTALL THE SYSTEMS.
VERY UNCLEAR IN CALIFORNIA THREE
OF OUR MEMBERS FACEBOOK GOOGLE
AND MICROSOFT THE THOUGHT CAMPUS
REDEVELOPMENT PLANS AND THERE'S
NO CLEAR PERMITTING PATHWAY TO
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE FACEBOOK.
AND HAS A HAS BEEN PERSON
PURSUING A PERMIT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN FOR SYSTEM
THAT CAN SAVE SEVENTEEN MILLION
GALLONS ANNUALLY.
AND FINALLY THREE COUNTIES AND
CITIES THEY NEED STATE GUIDANCE
AND WE ARE PART OF A LOCAL WATER
AND EFFICIENCY TASK FORCE BACK%
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BUT
CITIES THE COUNTY IN THE WATER
DISTRICT.
AND WE DEVELOPED A MODEL
ORDINANCE BUT BE IT'S BEEN
REALLY HARD TO GET IT PASSED
BECAUSE THERE'S A RELUCTANCE.
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE LACK OF
SEEK GUIDANCE.
SO SB NINE SIX SIX INCLUSION IT
WILL ADDRESS BOTH THESE OF
OBJECTION.
OBJECTIONS BY ESTABLISHING
TREATMENT SYSTEM PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS THAT ARE PROTECTIVE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PROVIDE GUIDANCE
FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES.
A SMART BILL KEEP THE PUBLIC
HEALTHY PROVIDES GUIDANCE AND UP
PERMITTING PATH FOR BUSINESSES.
IT WILL RESULT MARK COMMITTEES
TAKING A MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN
CONSERVING WATER IN THE FUTURE
AS WE FACE A GROWING POPULATION
AND CLIMATE CHANGE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SPORT [inaudible]
ANDREA.
YOU'RE KNOWN AS A FREQUENT FLYER
I'M A FREAK A FLYER TODAY US
WITH ANDREA OF INTERACT WITH
CLEAN WATER ACTION INSOFAR THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I'VE DONE UP LOTS WITH
CALIFORNIA'S WILL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION THERE WAS ACTUALLY.
AN ERROR IN THE ANALYSIS WE ARE
NOT OPPOSING THE BILL WE HAVE
THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THE SENATORS EFFORTS TO BRING
THIS ISSUE TO LIGHT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
HIS OFFICE [inaudible]
THANK YOU. THREE SEPARATE*
ON BEHALF OF CERES AND THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT AND I'D ALSO
LIKE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT OF
AMENDED ON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN HIS STUFF
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
ANY IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THAT'S NICE.
OKAY --
MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
MR MATHIS YOU KNOW WE I WISH WE
HAD YEAR MORE OFTEN WE WE CAN
ARRANGE THAT.
HOME.
I EVER GOT ONE CONCERN FOR YOU
--
SENATOR MOVING THIS FORWARD AND
IT DEALS WITH THAT THE QUALITY
--
BE CAREFUL WHEN LOOKING AT THE
QUALITY STANDARDS AND I SAY THIS
JUST FOR THE SIMPLE FACT THAT
BOTTLED WATER QUALITY STANDARDS.
ARE ACTUALLY LOWER THAN GRAY
WATER STANDARDS.
AND RESIDENTS USUALLY DON'T LIKE
THE IDEA OF TOILET TO TAP.
SO AS YOU IS YOU GUYS ARE
LOOKING AT WHAT THOSE STANDARDS
ARE GONNA BE FOR THAT QUALITY
JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND IN IN A
STILL BAFFLES ME TO THIS DAY
THAT.
BOTTLED WATER HAS A LOWER
STANDARD THAN.
ARE ARE RECYCLED WATER TREATMENT
[inaudible]
ON AND SO IT'S SOMETHING WE
DEFINITELY NEED TO LOOK AT
MOVING FORWARD BUT NAY I THINK
YOU'RE ON THE RIGHT TRACK AND I
THINK THIS LIVE LIKE.
HUGE ADDED BENEFIT TO AT YOUR
LOCAL ECONOMIES IN OUR PEOPLE
FAKE.
WELL THEY'RE VERY GOOD.
OF WE'VE HA THEIR MOTION AND A
SECOND.
AND SO I THINK --
DO YOU DO ON THE CLOTHES.
QUESTION I DON'T ALRIGHT.
ARM GREAT BILL [inaudible]
RECOMMENDED I GO FORWARD.
THIS IS SB NINE SIX SIX WIENER.
THE MOTION AS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MATHIS
[inaudible]
MATHIS I KALRA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I HOLDEN.
WHAT IT'S WATCHING MERETZ RICHIE
I?
ALRIGHT CONGRATULATIONS YOUR
SEATS OUT.
AND THAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THIS OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES --
ARE FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS TO
COME AND SO THAT WOULD BE TOLD
TEN MINUTES OF FOR NOW WE'RE
WAITING FOR MISTER CALDERON
[inaudible]
AND MISTER HOLDEN IN THE
MEANTIME --
I THINK [inaudible]
MISTER ARAMBULA ARE YOU THE ONLY
ONE LEFT AT ON IT WILL GET
THROUGH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I WELL LET'S SEE WHERE MR
[inaudible]
NO.
YET WHEN IT WE START WITH THE SP
TWO ONE TWO JACKSON.
S. B. TWO ONE TWO JACKSON
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I SO THAT BRINGS A VOTE
TO FOUR ONE THAT PASSES ANYWHERE
WANT TO THANK AGAIN --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS IN LACKEY
FOR BEING HERE AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR VERY GOOD QUESTIONS AS WELL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO LET'S I HIT THE REST OF THE
BILLS THAT MISTER ARAMBULA
DOCTOR ARAMBULA NEEDS TO ADD ON
TO I ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
I'M GLAD.
AND I'M GLAD I THIS IS THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN I ON S. B. TO TWELVE WE
HAVE THE VOTED.
FOUR TO ONE HOLDEN.
I CHAIR VOTING I THIS IS I S. B.
TWO TWELVE JACKSON.
S. B. TWO TWELVE JACKSON HOLDEN.
AYE THAT BRINGS THE VOTE FINAL
VOTE. TWO FIVE ONE SB NINE SIXTY
SIX WIENER.
CHAIR VOTED AYE THE VOTES AT
FIVE ZERO HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE.
SB NINE NINE EIGHT DODD.
VOTERS AT TWO ONE CHAIR VOTING
AYE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE SO THAT BRINGS THE
VOTE. TWO FOUR ONE THAT PASSES
OUT.
S. B. TWELVE FIFTEEN HERTZBERG.
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO HOLDEN
[inaudible]
HOLDEN I S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
THREE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
FOUR ZERO ARAMBULA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I READ IT TO SEE.
S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
PORTANTINO.
VOTES AT FOUR ZERO ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
ARAMBULA I HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE.
S. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE HILL.
THE VOTE IS AT FOUR ZERO
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE [inaudible]
SARAH.
SJR TWENTY TWO WESSEL.
VOTERS AT FOUR ZERO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE HOLDEN [inaudible]
HOLDEN I ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU --
WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR MISTER
CALDERON NOW
[inaudible]
NO THEY
SACRAMENTO.
SOME OF THEM.
THANK YOU DOCTOR.
I LOVE IT.
YEAH BUT I THINK YOU CAN COME
BACK.
YEAH WE HOW COME YOU KNOW IF I
CAN GIVE THEM AFTER I ALRIGHT I
DON'T AYE IT.
MYSELF REYES.
NO YOU PRETTY GOOD BELOW IT IT
MAKES EVERYTHING.
WHEN NO WE ON THE [inaudible]
PUBLISHED MONTH [inaudible]
A FAMILY [inaudible]
ONE CLOSE
ALL THE BILL'S GOT NOW SO WE ARE
NOT GOING TO WAIT FOR THE LAST
MEMBER TO COME AN ADD ON THANK
YOU [inaudible]
RIGHT